Is it working?
Am I live?
Get it out of me!
Hello!
Oh god, my voice is so dead.
My voice is so dead.
Oh my god, just like me.
Thank you.
You are dead.
I am.
That's why I said just like me.
Hold on one second, I'm gonna refresh YouTube real quick.
Okay, I think...
I haven't been around for many streams lately because of work, life, and football.
But I'm glad to start watching again.
I miss mint.
Hakuno and welcome back.
Thank you.
Oddballboy, thanks for the five.
My flight leaving Long Beach got delayed till Thursday.
You were basically me.
That's when I was going to get back.
It was Thursday.
But...
Now I'm home.
What a mess did Cloud Strife cause.
You would have missed your anniversary.
I know, right?
I have a convention I'm even doing this weekend.
And I had to contact them and been like...
I don't know if I'm gonna make it home in time.
Let's talk a bit about...
I was gone the past couple of days.
I was at...
MGS Con!
Yippee!
I know, I don't know, maybe if you watch Barry...
You heard some of these already.
She talked some...
Did you see the Nendos?
Of course I did!
I went to...
MGS Con.
In case you're after, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Randall, thanks for the 5 gifted.
I think I saw Teacup.
Yeah, thanks for the gifted!
Spent all the weekend dealing with your crowd buddies.
Looking back, I'm excited to finally meet you at Anime Fest.
I'm a little nervous.
That's this weekend!
Yeah!
Randall, thanks for the 10 gifted!
So...
It was truly...
The whole situation with the Cloud Strike was like...
It is Cloud Strike, right?
Right.
And Draco, thanks for the 20!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yes, okay.
Oh, Crowd Strike.
Wait, wait, is it Cloud Strike or Crowd Strike?
I'm glad you had fun at MGS Con.
I know it's been a while, but I wanted to give you an update about that interview.
I got the job!
That's my president!
So it is!
Congratulations!
Was that not a bit?
No, wait.
What's the...
What's the bit?
I'm always serious.
What are you talking about?
But no!
I went to MGS Con this past weekend.
Which is a one-day Metal Gear themed convention.
I got to see Maddy!
Oh my god.
The music is so dramatic.
The music!
Minecraft loves Maddy.
Good morning, Mito!
Good morning, Mito.
And...
The timing.
Yeah...
I don't know.
Maybe there are some people that had like a...
A spiritual awakening?
A sixth sense moment?
I'm not sure.
But if you sensed...
If you had a...
If you had a little chill...
It might have been me.
But I was definitely haunting Barry.
Basically the entire time.
Shout out to Barry.
Barry Bug.
The Better Bug.
Better than...
She's the best bug.
I've never known a better bug than Barry the Bug.
The audio is so loud!
Turn down!
But...
Nice tongue twister.
Say that times fast.
Barry Bug the Better Bug.
Welcome back, boss.
Happy early anniversary.
Yippee!
Thank you!
Cloud Strife?
Yes.
Basically.
Don't know any other bug.
But...
Yeah.
I was really grateful because...
Honestly...
I...
She is streamed on...
She streams on Twitch.
But she streamed yesterday.
I believe it was.
Sorry.
My time is all discombobulated.
I don't know what day it is.
I don't actually...
Is it...
It's Tuesday.
Isn't it?
Right?
I actually have no idea...
What day it is.
But...
Time is...
Time is an illusion.
Okay.
It is Tuesday.
Well...
Tuesday for me.
So...
Wednesday for you?
Okay.
But...
I'll explain.
It's...
In a minute.
Um...
I was really grateful because Matara wasn't able to make it to the con.
And I was gonna be all alone.
All by my lonesome.
And...
Like...
Barry talked about how she like stalked me.
But truly I was haunting her the whole time.
I'd be like...
Oh...
So Barry...
What do you...
Um...
Did you wanna go something...
Did you have another thing you wanted to do next?
Oh...
You...
No...
You wanna do what I wanna do?
What do you want to do?
So...
I was just like...
She and I being awkward together was so good.
Um...
It's Minto time.
Good evening Minto.
Good evening.
Um...
Do you guys like the new emotes?
Do you guys like them?
I have no more slots anymore.
So if we want more emotes...
Like we're maxed out.
If we want any more emotes, we have to...
Switch them out...
Do you know what day it is?
Well tomorrow is a different day.
It's April 30th.
Have fun playing Minecraft.
Thank you, Polly!
You did good, boss.
Yippee!
Emotes are pretty good.
So my flight, luckily, was only a little delayed.
Into the con weekend.
So I get there.
And honestly, I just like, have no idea what to do.
I'm just sitting in the lobby like...
I'm people watching.
Because I'm like, look at everybody walking around with their Metal Gear T-shirts!
Oh sorry, I'm starting to get emotional.
And all their merch and their bags and everything.
So great.
Why are flight delays so common?
Is it common in North America?
No, no!
It was because of the cloud strike.
The cloud strike.
Got a text saying it might be delayed again.
What flight...
Oh wait, don't actually...
Don't tell me your airline.
Because, you know, I don't want you to...
But, I heard that...
Oh, crowd strike.
Thank you, sorry.
Crowd... crowd strike.
I heard that some airlines are doing more poorly than others, so...
Felt chilly at MGS Con.
I even saw floating UOs and a big stinky aura.
What are you talking about?
Wasn't that Barry that went off about how good I smelled?
Which I...
She kept talking about how good I smelled.
And I didn't get, like, secondhand embarrassment.
I felt like I was...
I was like, is this how it feels when people listen to me talk?
I felt...
I felt like too much...
I was hearing too much of myself from her.
And I was really embarrassed about it.
I was like...
I was like, no way, this is how I sound?
Unreliable narrator?
What are you talking about?
I envy the bug I will squish.
But...
No...
I think...
I mean...
I think ectoplasm smells kinda good.
Exactly how you understand.
Why do you guys watch me?
That is...
Kind of my whole feeling.
That's kind of what I...
I got a lot of emotions this weekend.
But one of them was truly...
Why do people watch me?
I think you've all gaslit yourself into...
Into finding me enjoyable.
I swear.
At last you understand.
Two of them.
Because we're all weirdos.
But I got to meet...
Oh my gosh.
I met David Hayter for the first time.
I talked about this too.
In the...
Twitter space that I did.
But in case you didn't watch that.
And also...
Stockholm ourselves into loving you.
Loving you...
Is not easy.
You are horrible.
I've stockholmed myself...
Into loving you.
That poster story was so funny.
Oh!
I was like...
Poster story?
I like...
Oh my gosh.
I went up to David Hayter.
Like tears forming in my eyes.
I'm like...
I can't cry.
First of all.
Because I don't want to cry in front of him.
Second of all.
Because...
I don't want Barry seeing me cry.
I was like...
Oh god.
And I go...
Oh my gosh.
But I go up to him.
And I saw that he had a print of...
MGS Delta.
Snake.
And I was like...
Wow.
He's so fast.
And I like the Delta design.
And oh...
I don't know.
I like it.
And so I...
I was like...
Can I...
I got an autograph.
And then I bought that as an additional autograph.
And...
I'm showing...
Oh my gosh.
After he signs it...
And I kind of was just like...
You...
You've made my entire career.
And he was just like...
Hi.
Haha.
What are you...
What?
I'm like...
You...
I...
Everything shifted at that moment.
And...
He was like...
Oh...
What?
I know, right?
And...
So he's signing it.
And I'm like...
Not even paying attention to the print.
I'm just like...
Trying to hold my...
My composure.
I'm just like...
Oh gosh.
If I...
If I let one crack...
You know how like...
The dam has cracks.
And if just a little bit gets through...
Everything gets through?
That's how it was gonna be.
And so...
Um...
But...
Afterwards he signs it.
And then...
He...
Gets up from the table.
And walks over to Barry and I.
He didn't have to do this.
But he like...
Puts his hand on both of our shoulders.
And he goes...
By the way...
You're pretty good.
Haha.
Sorry.
He said it to everybody.
We weren't special.
But...
Oh my god.
What a dream.
David Hayter is just a very handsome guy.
Maddie and I are convinced...
If you've never seen...
So basically...
He starred in a movie called...
Guyver 2.
The second one.
Guyver.
And like...
He's...
He...
Back then...
He was...
I mean...
He's still very attractive.
But...
Back then he was like...
Such like a heartthrob.
You know?
He seems very nice.
He was so nice.
He...
You can tell he loves what he does.
You know what I mean?
But...
We kind of...
Maddie and I have like...
Determined that like...
He...
He is like...
Same level of like...
Harrison Ford.
Like...
In a parallel universe...
This guy is like...
Harrison Ford levels of famous.
He's like this heartthrob that everybody loves.
But...
In this universe...
He's just...
He's just a little too nerdy.
To like...
He's just a little bit too much of a dork maybe.
If you like him so much why don't you marry him?
Pretty sure he's already married.
But also...
I think I would throw up every day.
Probably hearing his voice.
Harrison Ford could have gone nerd but death did not.
Yeah!
We met...
Christopher Randolph who is the voice of Otacon.
Who is just a total absolute sweetheart.
And I know Barry just spilled our absolute spaghetti.
Thank you guys for all the super chats by the way.
I'm trying to like...
You talk about me so differently but you didn't recognize my favorite character.
Hold on.
I have a story for that later.
Can you play the game?
Oh my gosh.
Stop!
I...
I'm talking first.
What do you mean?
Okay.
I'm done.
I'll...
See.
I'm done.
I'm done talk...
Okay.
I won't talk anymore.
Let's just play...
Let's just play the game.
Okay.
I'm stuck on this block and I don't really know...
Do I break it?
Oh.
Yipee.
That's so unfair.
What.
She won the game.
Why am I losing bricks?
Oh wait.
Maybe I should build around too.
Right?
So that things don't drop.
Please place other blocks.
I'm working on it!
Guys!
Let me finish my art!
One black at a time.
Yeah, so we met him.
He was very nice.
Everybody was very nice.
One of my favorite people to meet was Paul Eiding.
And it's so crazy.
New Journey.
Place 20 blocks.
Oh my gosh!
Sorry!
There was...
I put a pin on my desk and I thought it was a bug.
My sensei pin.
From the hand cam, I thought it was a bug.
And I scared myself.
I scared myself looking at it.
Oh gosh.
You guys...
Okay, let me just tell you a little bit about my journey today, right?
I'm on like...
Very few hours of sleep.
What?
Stop running away from me!
I'm on very few hours of sleep.
Because I took a red eye.
And um...
Wah!
Arigato!
Arigato-chu!
Merl!
Thank you!
Getting in early on saying happy anniversary, your streams.
Since your comeback have been the most fun I've ever had with a Vtuber.
Shut up!
No way!
I can't...
I can't wait to see what else you do.
P.S.
I was on a conference call.
With the CEO of CloudStripe today.
He seemed pretty sorry.
Oh my gosh!
Thank you so much for the Big Dodo!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Merl!
But yeah, I took a red eye.
Which means...
Oh shoot.
Moss!
Which is a very...
Very late flight.
If you don't know, right?
It means it's like a flight really late in the night.
And um...
So...
What had happened was...
I...
I was actually checking into my flight.
And I was like putting in my bags.
Because I had to check a bag.
And I was putting it in.
And it was like...
It was like...
Oh by the way, we can't check your bag.
There's something wrong.
And I was like...
Oh.
That's weird.
And then when I...
I'm doing this on the app, right?
And when I go back to the app...
Or when I go back to my check-in screen...
It's like...
We're sorry your flight is cancelled.
And I was like...
What do you mean by that?
I love red eyes.
I don't.
And so...
I was like freaking out.
I was like...
I was panicking just a little bit.
How do I get underneath?
Thank you.
It's like...
Hey, by the way, you can make a thing.
And...
Oh, water.
Ah, water, water, water.
But...
Let's make some utensils, right?
So...
I'm like...
Searching...
The one flight...
It like...
It automatically rebooked me for some reason.
Thanks, Rico!
I heard that Southwest was completely unaffected because they're still running everything on Windows 3.1.
Which hasn't been updated in 25 years!
What?
Maybe I should have taken Southwest then.
You mean tools?
Oh.
Yeah.
So...
You guys, I'm test...
Hold on.
Let me finish.
Sorry.
I got an Amber Alert all of a sudden.
What's
happening?
What's going on?
Wake up.
Um...
And...
Where was I?
Um...
Okay.
So...
So I'm like...
It puts me on a flight on Thursday.
And...
Actual jump scare.
Puts me on a flight on Thursday.
Let's make some shovel too.
And I was like...
No!
That's too late!
I'll miss my stream!
I'll miss my anniversary stream!
I'll miss...
I'll miss my convention!
Appearance!
I can't do this!
And...
So...
Um...
I'm like struggling.
I'm like on the phone with them for three hours.
I'm on hold for so many hours trying to get a person to give me a refund or something.
There was another flight that I found that uh...
But it wouldn't let me rebook it.
It was just a bunch of craziness.
And so I'm like...
Oh my god.
Could I request a lullaby?
I'm going in and out of sleep.
If not a simple stupid fries works.
That hurt.
Are you okay?
Go to sleep.
Go to sleep little baby.
Close your eyes.
Go to sleep.
Um have sweet dreams of...
Thighs.
Close your eyes.
Meat, cheese, fries.
Oh god I feel so sleepy.
And you'll...
Crash!
Wait, which is the one block?
Glad you got home safe and time.
Thank you!
Wait, hold on.
I gotta put on some music.
Oh, hold on.
What do we want to listen to?
Minto's thighs.
What are you thinking about?
Put on Lullaby music?
Oh, this one's called Smoothie House.
This is a jazzy...
Limp Bizkit.
People are trying to sleep!
People are trying to sleep.
Everybody be quiet.
Stop the chat.
Is this it?
Is this the one, right?
Okay, good.
Go to sleep.
Little baby.
Think of suckling on a nip.
Just like when you were a baby.
And you just suckled the tip.
Little baby dreams.
Baby world.
Think... imagine... put yourself as a baby.
Your scream woke me up.
With my jump scare that I thought it was a bug.
Every single stream, I'm left asking myself...
How are you even real?
Well, some people say ghosts aren't real.
Gives me a bit of an existential crisis.
You know?
Oh my god.
Mysterious traitor!
I can order a cat!
Sorry, I didn't mean to scream so much.
Maybe I should trade...
Oh, I don't have enough dirt.
I don't have anything.
Get out of here.
Get off my land.
Get off my land, please.
Okay, anyway.
Oh, that's my shovel.
Sorry.
I'm really jumpy.
Like I said, I took a really late flight.
And the day before my flight, all I did...
I...
You guys, I didn't know what to do.
I was...
So, MGS Con was Saturday.
Sunday, Maddie and I walked around the beach.
We...
I...
I got sunburnt a little bit.
On my head.
But we walked around the pier.
And the beach.
And we just...
You know.
So, I did walking then.
And then the day after...
Then...
That was before I even knew anything would be canceled.
And...
And I...
I'm scared of mob spawning.
I'm gonna turn it down just a little bit more.
Okay.
And...
Touch grass.
Haha.
Touch sand.
Yeah.
We touch sand.
But...
You scream more here than in a horror game.
I'm sorry.
I'm really...
My brain is not quite working.
I didn't know what to do.
So, I ended up...
I ended up trying to go to a museum.
And...
It was closed.
Oh, no!
I can't!
What's step two?
Mind the block.
A hundred...
Oh, boy.
I tried to go to a museum.
Apparently, everything is closed on Mondays.
Which is really just...
So sad.
Um...
Oh, I tried to go to two museums.
And they...
Everything was closed.
So, I ended up, like, just walking.
I ended up walking for, like, ten minutes.
Like, ten miles.
Like no joke.
Hypothetical situation.
Your OSHI is talking to you about the hypothetical situation of your OSHI seeing your nipples.
Oh!
What would you do?
Um...
So, my OSHI talks about...
If my OSHI talked about seeing my nipples, is what you're saying.
Hmm...
Hmm... Sounds like... I did something correct.
Um...
Look.
Jeff...
If you're still around... If I didn't scare you off...
If I didn't... So, there was a guy...
At the convention... Dressed as Raiden...
And I'm getting flamed online for this.
He was dressed as Raiden.
And... He was in a towel.
With his little Raiden wig on and everything.
He was dressed... As Raiden.
And I was like, oh it's just like that scene in MGS2.
And I was like...
How is that... How is me seeing Raiden...
Seeing Raiden...
In a towel...
Not at like...
You are correct.
Did he do the cartwheel?
He should have.
In fact... How disappointing that he didn't.
How disappointing.
How big Chung's life was MGSCon?
Sounds like it was a lot of fun.
Wish I could have gone.
It was so much fun!
I hope they do it again next year.
I'm too embarrassed to hear what Berry said about me.
So anything she said about me was probably a lie.
Just... Just... Just think of... Just believe that...
Don't believe Andor's lies.
Anything... Anything she said about me...
Is a total fabrication.
We can build trees!
Tomorrow is my birthday!
Coincidentally the same day as your anniversary!
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course not!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Matt!
So...
I don't know.
Like I said, I couldn't really listen to her talk about how...
How much I smelled.
Minecraft music.
Oyma!
Berry literally said you are the sweetest person.
Um...
And...
Everything she says...
I said what I said!
I'm not a good... I'm not a good ghost.
I'm an evil ghost.
When will you guys understand?
God!
She...
You...
You compared him to getting embarrassed to watching Meryl turning right in front of a thousand listeners.
Put yourself in their shoes.
Also, Berry went on a whole existential crisis because of how nice you were.
Well, that's how awesome I felt too.
Like... I don't know.
Being...
Being in a place where I...
Maybe... I don't know.
If you guys went to Off-Kai...
Maybe...
Maybe you had like a similar...
Like...
A similar...
Existential crisis where you're just like...
It truly...
It truly made me just be like...
Oh my gosh...
Maybe...
Maybe people are just nice, you know?
Maybe people are...
Like...
When you're surrounded by people that are...
You know...
Involved in your fandom...
And just something that you really love...
And something that is so...
You know...
You're so passionate about...
And you hold in such high regard...
And you never want to ever let go...
And you're so sad that it's over...
And you're just like...
Oh my gosh...
When...
I have nothing else to look forward in my life...
To now...
Or my afterlife...
Because...
It's over...
And you just see how nice everybody is...
You're just like...
Just makes you feel like...
Maybe...
Maybe there is some good in this world...
No...
I'm just saying...
I mean...
I just don't wanna...
Go around...ridding style... I'm see... So beautiful...
And just be beautiful... And receive...
The love of your life...
That that's what a person should be like... It's love...
an... Hello, Well... I think it's...
A ...
Lu...
I was just like, you're so nice.
And I'm just like, I didn't do anything.
I didn't do anything.
It does make you think or like, you know, it makes you like...
kind of remember like, you know, when people are so poopy online.
Nine times out of ten, they're not like that in person.
And it's like, oh my gosh, maybe touching grass is important.
Maybe they actually, maybe I should touch grass more.
I don't know.
Turns out people love you because you're great.
I was haunting everybody.
And then also, I got to meet Cynthia Harrell.
Which I only saw her in concert before.
I got to actually meet her and talk to her.
And I got to tell her that I went to the MGS concert.
Touch grass?
Never!
I got to tell her that I went to the concert because of her.
And how much of an inspiration she is to me.
And she's just such a nice lady.
And she sings Snake Eater.
She's the singer of Snake Eater.
And...
I got to...
The crazy thing is I actually got to sing Snake Eater with her.
But it wasn't just me.
I mean, it was like a crowd.
But then also, I was invited to a party with Maddie.
After the con was over.
And she was at the party.
And then we also sang Snake Eater again.
And I was just like...
What is this?
What is this life?
What is going on?
I hope you've had a great day.
I've always been a lurker.
I just want to know how you're special to me.
Thank you, Cyber!
Wait.
What's her profile picture?
Is that Hoshino from Blue Archive?
Mention it during my haunting.
Oh, you sensed me?
Developed a sixth sense?
You might want to get...
You might want to go get blessed or something, you know?
Can you move?
Can you like...
Please, leave me alone.
I thought you would disappear or something.
What is this?
Stone!
Stone, stone, stone.
Boom!
Mint experiencing the good of people.
Also Minecraft being more of a jump scare than usual.
It's because...
You know.
Things like pop up, you know?
Do not come to European content.
All the EU wisps want to dribble you like a basketball for time...
time zone crimes.
And it'll ruin our image.
No!
Go back now!
Actually, I mentioned this recently.
How like...
Um...
The reason I haven't been able to do...
You can blame Matara for the reason I haven't been able to do so many...
So many...
Early day...
Streams.
Me dribbling.
I thought you meant dribble like you were gonna dribble your spit on me.
Oh my gosh!
Lacuna!
Thank you so much for the pink!
Fancy seeing you play Minecraft Love Black.
Maybe you'll find a music disc that says...
Sounds like VTuber BGM or something.
What?
So glad you had an amazing time at MGSCon and got to meet two MGS OGs.
Looking forward to more Minta forever.
Thank you!
But um...
The reason it's Matara's fault is because of the podcast.
Because...
Uh oh, wait.
Which one is it?
Wait, which one is it?
Oh no, no, no.
Is it this one?
Uh oh.
Oh!
Okay, it's this one.
Wait, he's gonna fall.
Nevermind.
Because of the podcast, she...
She...
I have to keep my days open because I'll be like, Hey Matara, we gotta record the podcast.
And she's like, I'm gonna stream.
I really wanna stream.
And I'm like, yeah, me too.
But like...
Then she'll sometimes just like...
You know...
Go away.
Love you, Minto.
Thank you!
So you can...
You can...
Blame her.
Place slabs around it.
You're so smart!
I was hearing you and Barry talk about if JSCon is giving me FOMO.
Oh, anyways.
However, I'm glad I got to see you at Off Guy.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He was crying about Time Zone and then there's...
Us NA folks very grateful you're streaming at such friendly ESC timing.
You asked Maria how she would feel if you saw...
If...
Wait.
If her Oshii saw her in a towel.
No?
Really appreciate you, Minto.
I'm sick.
Oh no!
I just feel better!
There are dribblers.
Like b-ball.
And there are dribblers.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Okay, love song...
STOP IT!
I don't wanna hear this anymore.
Oh, the music disappeared.
Just like a baby.
I'm dribbling like a baby.
Oh my gosh, this is a pain in the butt.
Having to switch tools.
When do I enter the Stone Age?
Maybe I can.
Maybe I can make a stone.
Maybe I can make a stone!
Yes!
Yeah, but would you lose?
A baby dribbling contest?
Or... wait.
Oh no!
Is this the one?
Oh gosh.
Yes, okay.
Oh, actually since I just made this pickaxe, let's get rid of it first.
Nice.
Yeah, more stone.
Nah, I'd win.
If there was a competition...
Any sort of competition, I think I'd win.
I'm not so weak.
Did you know that mint was a singular leaf?
Are you saying I'm all by my lonesome?
What is going on up here?
If there was a competition of any sort...
I'm no loser.
I'm gonna win anything.
How about a being tall competition?
I hate you!
I hate...
This...
Is unfair!
How could you go so low?
Those don't exist.
Tall competitions.
They'll never exist.
When I become president, I will make sure of it.
How could you go so low?
Tall competitions do exist.
No?
Tell me.
Never thought I'd be putting up with a competition like this.
What?
Hello?
I never thought I'd hear mint say the word hate.
No.
I have a lot of hate in my body.
I'm sorry.
Again, like I said, I'm an evil ghost.
Oh!
We got a new guy!
He'll give us jungles.
We can get seeds!
Wait, you guys.
You guys!
Guys, can we afford all of this?
Okay, that's 45.
Let's just buy it all.
Oh, I was gonna say we had just enough.
We can order a sheep.
Buy!
Okay, get out of here.
Actually, no.
Oh wait, he's gonna reset.
Go out.
Go away.
Go.
Bye-bye.
Bye!
I just lost the spelling competition because that should have been pro basketball game.
What?
Barry told us to ask you about the special thing you did.
Special thing?
Hold on, let me message her.
I don't even know what she...
What's the special thing?
What's the special thing I did?
Mintz killed a man?
I ran over a baby this morning actually.
Ran
over a baby this morning.
With my suitcase.
At the airport.
And the mom was like...
Cause the baby ran out in front of me.
Or rather behind me because I was pulling my suitcase.
The mom was like...
I'm so sorry!
And I was like...
I'm sorry!
I ran over your baby!
I
ran over a baby.
I kept running over people.
I tasted blood.
I'm a killer.
This is the skin of a killer Bella.
Lucky baby.
What's wrong with you?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I thought that was...
I forgot that was wood.
Or stone is what I meant to say.
Don't worry, you did the right thing.
The baby came out of nowhere.
And I mean...
Like I said, I was pulling my suitcase.
And he ran out behind me.
And I just...
Right over his head.
The
mom apologized to me.
The mom apologized to me.
Oh my god, she could have...
I could have gotten eaten alive by that.
She could have been like...
You ran over my baby!
Wait, which one is it you guys?
Is it this one?
Someone said put slabs down for these bad boys.
Let's do that.
Slab.
I'm gonna put some slabs down.
Slab, slab, slab, slab.
For the child.
Amazing!
That right there is why you're the best.
Running over a baby with the MGS...
Merch suitcase?
No, that's the worst part.
This bag is heavier than my actual suitcase.
Because it has all my laptop stuff in it.
So it's even heavier!
It had my entire streaming set up.
The baby just took it all.
Like a damn champ.
Kids will just insert themselves in front of moving objects in ways that defy physics.
It's true.
Oh my gosh.
It was the first thing that happened after I got off the plane.
And so, I've been awake... I don't know.
Like I said, I did 9 miles yesterday.
And then, I went from... I went to my hotel.
I took a quick shower.
And then I...
Went to the airport after walking for so long.
Wisps are loyal AF.
I easy guide the child.
Don't lie.
We know you don't bathe.
No, it was the most... Okay.
I got the hotel room scared that I wouldn't be able to go home.
And it was a pricey hotel... What the hell is a mace?
What's a... What are these?
Heavy core?
Breeze rod?
I've never heard of any of this before.
But um... Try... Auto summary is wild.
What does it say?
It's a new weapon.
Really?
There's actual new stuff.
Onion.
I'm glad you guys like the new emotes.
I'm so happy.
But uh...
Yeah, so I walked and then I took a shower.
I paid for this hotel room thinking that I would be there longer.
And um...
So I basically was in the hotel room for like...
3 hours.
Cost me $200.
Most expensive shower of my life.
The baby gonna have a great story to tell when they're grown up.
I got run over by the one I didn't even expect.
Yeah, big oof.
Big oof.
The whole thing just put such a...
Put such a...
Damper on everything.
But!
And me walking around...
Which I still...
Even though I didn't get to go home on time...
I still had so much fun yesterday and...
Walking around and stuff even.
Because...
Even though I didn't get to go to...
The...
The museums.
Um...
I was walking and I was like trying to find like parks to just walk in.
And I saw like one that was like called a memorial park.
And I was like, oh!
Okay, cool.
Memorial park.
And I go there and I'm just walking laps and I...
Well, first I get there and I'm like, oh, this is just a straight up cemetery.
How...
How suiting for a ghost, right?
I was like, maybe I'll see some other ghosts here.
I don't know.
Um...
Maybe I can socialize.
Like I didn't do enough this week.
This past weekend.
And um...
And uh...
Oh my gosh.
When is this thing gonna grow?
He's got the cherry sapling!
Huh!
I must buy.
Prismarine shard.
We can live without for now.
Pale wolf.
But um...
I walked to the cemetery...
Through the cemetery.
And I noticed by one of the graves...
Um...
There's like kind of a group of people.
And I was just like, oh, I guess, you know, family.
You know, whatever, whatever.
The child incident was just an unfortunate speed bump.
On an otherwise great trip.
Yes.
Um...
But uh...
Later on, the group of people left.
And I'm looking at the grave.
And I was like...
Looking at it.
For a second.
And I was like, wait a second.
I recognize this.
It...
I recognize it from far away.
Because...
It's...
I see this.
And this might give it away.
It was covered in lipstick marks.
All over it.
And do you know what people do?
They go to Marilyn Monroe's grave and they kiss it.
It was Marilyn Monroe's grave.
I was like, woah!
Oh my gosh.
I just...
We...
It was just an accident that I was there.
I forgot, what...
Hold on.
I looked it up earlier.
I'm not sure what this place was called because I was also just like, what other, what other, um, did you talk to her?
She wasn't available, you know?
I mean, she's, she's a celebrity.
I'm a mint phantom, you know?
Did you kiss it?
No.
But, um, I had to stop myself from taking a picture of Big Boss in front of me.
I was like, maybe that's a little too far, but I
was looking out for who else is buried in that cemetery.
Apparently, it's like the most celebrity-filled cemetery, um, uh, like Jodie Fawcett's there, Peter Falk is there, Kojima would have done it, but
yeah.
I don't know.
I'm dead too, though, right?
I can get away with it.
Guys, I'm just as dead.
Wait, is this a new one?
No.
I'm just as dead!
It's okay when ghosts do it.
Yeah!
I mean, like, come on!
Right.
Get out!
Go away!
Where were you buried, Minto?
I don't know.
I think, uh, I don't know if I ever got a proper burial.
Outer heaven.
Good golly.
Shifur Gore.
It has been a long time since I died, so.
You know.
Oh, there goes my shovel.
Can it stop raining, please, for two seconds?
When am I gonna get some, like...
animals, like sheep and stuff?
Hmm, indeed.
Hmm.
After Zanzibar.
Happy anniversary.
Thank you.
Dead men tell no tales.
Are you dead?
Yeah?
I am dead.
You can be ashes on Venom Snake's face.
Ooh la la.
I'm glad you didn't eat him up like a cheeto does.
Dead men tell no tales.
What does that mean?
Like they don't tell stories?
Because what am I doing then?
You're the exception.
Really?
Why are my trees growing?
Do I need more dirt?
Grow!
Um, yeah, I get it.
Sophia!
Thank you for your help!
They can't testify in court.
So they're like, dead men can't snitch on you.
Dead men can't tell you where they...
how they died.
Stop!
He's trying to...
Go away, please.
Go away.
You're embarrassing.
Go.
They can't rat you out.
Exactly.
No witnesses.
But they didn't think about ghost maids.
No, they didn't.
Now he won't tell tales.
Dead men tell no tales.
He
wasn't a villager.
He was a mysterious trader.
He was a trader.
Maybe you have to water the trees.
Oh...
Why do I go through the things that I go through?
Why do I allow this?
I think being a Vtuber has truly changed.
What?
You're back!
It's got a cave shop.
Oh, we can get some gravel.
Let's get some gravel.
We can get some gold.
Beehive?
If only we had some bees.
Vtubers.
Vtubers have changed.
Wait, let's get a little...
Oh, wait.
I was gonna say let's plant our seeds but we have no water.
Hmm...
He must tell his tales.
Beehive.
Hmm...
You're so needy.
You're so close to me.
Why are you so obsessed with me, mysterious trader?
Why are you so obsessed with me?
Are you obsessed with me?
There he goes.
When is it gonna stop raining though?
For real?
Sounds familiar.
Maybe he's a wisp.
One thing though.
Like, you know, when I do cons and stuff, even if it's something like MGS con that I have absolutely no relation to, I'm just I'm just haunting for fun.
I'm not there to like, you know, be a guest or anything.
Which, oh!
I'm so sorry that it didn't work out with me appearing at the convention.
Like, I had everything set up and like, five minutes before the time, they sent me a message and they're like, we're behind schedule.
We have to cut.
We have to cut it.
I'm so sorry.
And I was like, it's okay!
Like, they were so, so apologetic.
Again, everybody at the convention was so nice.
Like, I can't I just can't be... I can't I can't be upset.
So, uh...
But, so I'm so sorry if you were just like, oh, I wonder if Minto's gonna show up.
Um, and it was just gonna be like a quick little thing anyway.
But, um...
It stopped raining!
Yippee!
Uh...
Next year, definitely.
Oh, maybe.
We'll see.
Um...
But, uh...
What was I saying?
Oh!
Even when it's something like MGSCon that I have no relation to, I truly, I'm just...
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna be...
I was gonna say I'm gonna be sappy.
You know what I was literally about to say?
I was literally about to say...
Oh my gosh.
Wisps are just...
the best.
Wisps are the best fandom.
You guys are the absolute best.
And then...
And then what appears?
None other than...
That...
I take
it all back.
I take it all back.
You guys are absolute freaks!
You guys are such freaks!
What's wrong with you guys?
Why can't you just be normal?
What is absolutely wrong with you guys?
Why do you say the things that you say?
Why are you so bold and brazen?
Why do you think that you can just say whatever you want?
We learn from you.
You did not learn!
You did not learn to ask people to poop on their chest because of me!
When have I ever said that?
That Supa is not a representation of the majority.
Chat reflects the streamer derogatory.
Don't lump me in with that!
And you know what the greatest insult of that is?
The greatest insult...
is um...
was...
the amount.
You'll make such a ridiculous demand, such a ridiculous request.
At that...
At that price?
Oh, an apple.
Can you get hungry in this version?
Sick freak.
We learn from the best boss.
If you want such a prized...
such a delicacy...
You must pay up.
Lump me in with the majority.
So would you reconsider at a different amount?
Well...
No, I didn't say that.
I'm just saying it was a little offensive, you know?
We're talking about Mint's secret...
Cleveland streamer instructional members video.
Huh?
What does that even mean?
What's a Cleveland streamer?
I just sat down.
You want us to do what?
Do not google.
Huh?
Cleveland streamer?
Is that from Idaho?
He's back.
Raw iron!
We need that for real.
Actually, I wonder if I can make a...
furnace now.
And then...
Oh, wait.
But I can...
Let him cook.
I can burn...
Like this, right?
There we go.
There we go!
These Supas need to cease?
What's going on with you guys?
I'm gone for like two days.
I wish to feed from the forbidden Play-Doh fun factory.
I googled it.
Don't do it.
That shit literally is sick.
What's going on?
What's happening?
Why are you guys such a...
What are you trying to introduce me to?
You guys...
Is Minecraft breaking your brains?
What's going on?
We got a call!
Come back!
Thank you for the 50 gifted.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
That is freaky, freaky tonight.
Come on, guys.
Let's dial it back a little bit.
Let's instead talk about murder.
Murder the man!
Murder, murder...
Murder, murder the man!
Don't...
Murder the man!
Let him live now!
I got all that I needed from him.
Time to gouge my eyes out.
You guys scare me.
We got a...
Dripstone!
Murder the man!
Messed up.
Dark, perverted fact.
Minto-chan is cute.
Chovek, go to sleep.
But yeah, once the...
Once the podcast is over, I'll be able to do more...
Mid-day thingies.
Right now, it's really just kind of...
Because Matara's schedule is like...
Kind of whack.
Oh!
Well...
Freak phantom.
What is your wisdom?
You two!
Go to sleep!
Meaches fries.
Detective Jones.
Thanks for the captain.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yesterday was my B-day!
But Friday will be my last day living...
In the house I spent my life in.
But birthday wish I'd much rather have.
Words of encouragement.
Much love from a wisp who's been here since your introduction video.
Helen!
You really have been around for so long.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
I know it can be scary.
Oh!
But...
You're...
You are taking a big step in your life.
And I believe that...
You will be just fine.
And happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Alan!
Good luck!
You got this.
In Minecraft, where's the music?
We got the advancement.
I am iron...
Let him cook.
When is this guy gonna grow up?
This little sapling.
Unrelated to Phonoceros, my beloved.
Diva, welcome to the membership.
Encore.
Onion.
There we go.
I like Minecraft music so much.
It's always so calming.
Not when the game is being so freaky.
Let's see.
Should I get an iron one or should I save it?
I always love your streams.
Well, anything you do, I'm kind of lost right now.
What do you do to make the bad brain worms go away?
Eat the brain worms.
Play Metal Gear Solid.
Yeah, replace them with...
Actually, that's such a good thing though.
Replace it with a different kind of brain worm.
You know?
Instead.
That way you don't have...
You don't have one brain worm.
You'll have a different type of brain worm.
That's a brain worm.
It could be a really more dangerous brain worm, but...
Worm eater!
I like how you can see the sun through the block.
Brain worm farm.
I don't know, because I have lots of brain worms.
I think about lots of things.
I have...
Okay, don't tell anybody, but I might...
I think I have, like...
Self-esteem issues, you know?
Oh my god, Pies!
You scared me!
Since we're in baseball season, do you think you'd be a better pitcher?
Wait.
Do you think you'd be better...
Be...
Better a pitcher or as a hitter?
I think a pit...
No.
Hitter.
I'd be a good hitter.
I think.
I've never played baseball once.
Man, self-esteem...
I said don't tell anybody.
Don't even...
Don't...
You know.
I know I'm a 10-side genius.
Perfect ghost maid.
But sometimes I have also problems.
Sometimes I have my...
I do have a little bit of flaws.
Not as much as you guys, but like...
You know.
I'm trying to brisket.
Oh.
I'm about to try a brisket.
What does it mean, trying a brisket?
Trying to brisket.
I've been cooking for the past two days.
Can you bless it with your maid powers?
Yeah!
Oh!
Make it delicious!
Moe!
Kyun!
There you go.
Moe!
Kyun!
Good evening, Minto.
Good evening.
Oh my gosh.
We're close to buying more things.
I want to order a cat.
So unfair.
Don't you...
Huh?
... Me.
You have nothing I want.
Leave.
Huh!
Goodbye.
Oh wait!
I can start making torches too.
Can't I?
Let's make 8.
Yay!
Now it's a little less spooky.
Get off!
She's killed so many people.
I told you, I'm a vengeful ghost.
My bagel just did a magical girl transformation into a cross sword.
What happened?
How did this turn into a block?
Wasn't it just bushes just a second ago?
How does it change like that?
I'm a boy, thanks for the fob, gifted.
But yeah, I don't know.
It's hard to say what else happened at the convention.
I talked about it mostly in the Twitter space.
Saving up my limited gacha bucks for a character with a huge gat coming out tomorrow.
Can you chaff the desire sensor for me?
Wait, in what game?
What game?
Zazamos.
I polled for Ako today in Blue Archive.
I didn't get her the first time or the second time.
But I got her the third time!
Oh, it's a ZZZ.
Is that game any good?
Is it a Hoyoverse?
I tend to not do Hoyoverse things, but...
The maid girls are really, you know, they're targeting me, I think.
It's cool.
What's the gameplay like?
Definitely Hoyoverse.
Three guys in it and everything.
Simple hack and slash with stages.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It doesn't sound, like, not fun.
Just, like, kind of thinking, like...
When I, like...
What's so great about, like, some of the gacha games is I can just kind of...
Kind of play them very casually.
You can skip cutscenes.
But that's how you see the characters, right?
Can't wait for horse gacha.
Soon till.
Current limited banner is a maid shark girl.
Yeah, I see art of her everywhere.
I see so much art of the maid shark girl.
People love her.
I mean, the design is really, really cute.
I know why.
I can see why.
They would be a fan.
Big sloppy tail.
Yeah.
But...
I don't know.
I just, ah...
I couldn't ever get into Genshin when I tried.
And...
I don't know.
Maybe it's just, like, the style of Hoyo-verse games for me.
Feel...
I don't know.
I don't know what it is.
I can't describe why.
The dailies are easy.
That's good.
In this one.
It's more persona-y with action combat.
Are the stories any good?
Maybe I will try as easy as I can.
But I can't do any more gacha.
Hi girly girl.
Hi little girly girl.
What?
Come here.
Pretty simple up to where I've gotten.
That's my cat.
Come here.
You gonna jump in my chair?
I'm making room for you.
Sit in my chair.
No?
Come here.
Oh my god, she just flopped on the ground.
She's such a plopper.
Gacha anonymous.
I really truly try to limit myself to one gacha.
And right now I'm so blue archive pilled that I can't look at anything else.
What are you doing stinky?
Stinky Johnny.
She's cleaning herself.
I think she's okay.
She might want to go eat soon though.
I'm doing three.
Kitty love.
She's just rolling around on the ground.
What are you looking at?
What's got your attention?
Is there a bug there?
What are you looking at?
You're scaring me.
Is there a bug?
Stop.
Why are you sniffing the ground like that?
There's nothing there.
She's having delusions.
Is this the lap kitty?
Well, she was supposed to be.
What is...
Summons a trial challenge when dropped into the void?
What is this?
Did you know Niki had a collab with Dave the Diver?
I did know that.
And I'm still confused how.
Hahaha.
I managed to pull best girl Ellen, the shark maid, earlier today while watching her maid cafe vlog.
So I thank you for having brought me the maid luck.
Of course.
Yippee.
I have mental brain worms.
Hey, stop.
That's my umbrella.
Stop it.
Oh my god.
She's chewing my umbrella.
Hold on.
Stop.
I'm going to let her out.
She's being a menace.
Stop.
Oh my god.
Stop it.
Stop.
You're going to put a hole in my...
She put a hole in my umbrella.
No.
Oh my god.
She put a hole in my...
This was my expensive umbrella.
No.
That's...
That's Venom's arm.
Stop it.
Huh?
She's such a menace.
My umbrella.
No.
I have umbrella fun.
Thank you.
No.
You don't have to.
I bought it last time I was in Japan and I got it at like a specialty umbrella store.
I was like, I'm going to splurge on an umbrella.
I was like, I'm going to splurge...
Oh.
I'm going to splurge on a nice umbrella.
Uchu toy.
I mean...
Uchu toy?
I mean umbrella fun.
Uchu toy.
Thank you.
She was like attacking his arm.
I...
I got some...
I took out like some stuff from a box that was sent to me from OFKAI.
She's a phantom menace.
Okay.
I need to do more.
I need to start building some stuff.
Expensive umbrella.
Umbrella lost or stolen.
$2 7-Eleven special and I'll have it for life.
I know!
Right!
The hall in between events or peek.
Let's see.
What should we start building?
Is that her cat?
Yeah, my cat!
My cat's name is Paz.
She's so sweet.
And also a menace.
We have some gravel.
Mangrove...
Am I good on food?
I'm not hungry.
Oh, chest!
Yeah, it's a good thing.
Chest.
Let's build that.
We can start storing everything.
Let's see.
Once we get some water.
I swear!
I remember like before when I played this.
Things would like... like animals would pop up.
But we haven't gotten a single animal yet.
A corral for animals.
More platform.
Yeah, I am gonna...
This one is different.
When can we expect to hear you voicing a character?
Milk.
How?
What Metal Gear game?
I haven't been able to catch a lot of your streams live, but your vibes have made lots of work days much more bearable.
So thank you for being so funny.
Also, goodnight, Wisp.
Minto won't tell you this, but you're very cute.
I'll say the Whisper Cue!
I'll say it!
I'll say it before you!
I said it first.
I said it before Chovek.
I said... I said the Whisper Cue before... before Chovek even ever thought...
Before Chovek even came out the womb, I was thinking that Wisps are so cute.
I said it before you were even a concept.
Before you were even... before you were even implemented into this... into this world.
Thanks, Chovek.
Goodnight.
No!
Don't thank Chovek!
Thank me!
Where's your loyalty?
Don't thank Chovek!
It was my idea to say that Wisps are so cute.
Always have been.
Now I kinda wanna take it back.
When you guys get cocky about it, I kinda wanna take it back.
Okay, let's start building also like... maybe a fence.
Chovek, my Oshii!
What?
We're as cute as you?
Don't insult yourself like that.
Oh my gosh.
Um, fence.
Except the one area we have... for murder.
There we go.
Oh wait, actually we need a few more... for sticks.
Thirty-three.
That should be... maybe good.
If I do this.
Now, I'm not just making a pen here.
I'm making like a whole little outline.
This is MY island in the sky.
And no one else is allowed to join.
No one else is allowed in.
No one else can join... well, um...
Cute as mint, but taller.
But you play Ace Combat 4-5-0-7.
I would like to play more Ace Combat, yes.
But... please be patient.
Because I'm working on other stuff first.
But eventually, yeah.
Not even snakes?
Snakes not coming in!
Oh my gosh, that would be such a great addition.
Not... not solid snake.
But snakes in... in Minecraft will be so fun.
...
Shorter is better?
You think so?
I think people are always exaggerating my height, though.
You see...
I am NOT the size of a pinky.
I actually am of... of normal size.
Oh my god, no, he's... he's... he's learning.
He knows that he can't le... that he... will...
We're good, we're good.
Okay, push, push.
Push, push, push.
Push, push.
Push!
Yeah!
I'm a pretty average size, I think.
I don't think it's Culp.
I think it's, you know...
I think it's normal.
We're the Shire?
What do you call a cookbook filled with French dessert recipes written by a ghost maid?
A Mont...
Mont...
Mont Blanc tome.
You give off such nine centimeter energy.
I don't know why.
You're standing at virtual vacations as otherwise.
Yeah, but when I'm standing next to two very... or three very tall people, of course the perspective is going to be off.
Minto Baggins.
Let's see.
Let's create like a ledge of death.
Ledge of de...
Did something form?
Wait, did you guys see...
Did you guys see something pop up there real quick or am I crazy?
Did you guys see that or...
Am I crazy?
Maybe I'm crazy.
That means I'm crazy.
Not me, not crazy.
I'm so brain dead.
I'm so...
You guys, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for how brain dead I am today.
I've got maybe like three hours of sleep.
Of rested sleep, you know.
Something did pop up but you're still crazy.
Okay, see?
See?
Gman's a real one.
Telling it...
Telling it as it is.
Something popped up.
But, you know...
I'm actually loopy.
Herobrine!
They wouldn't put him...
In this.
When am I gonna get stuff though?
For like...
Like sheep and stuff.
Do I have to trade for the sheep?
I have to get diamonds?
I have to keep going?
We have to keep digging deeper?
Or would they?
That's so evil.
They wouldn't do that.
What one block version is this?
I actually have no idea.
It's very different from the one that I did before.
I think it's a little...
It feels a little slower.
Oh!
God!
We can get some string.
Yeah, it's 1.21.
You're right.
Oh!
We can order a cow!
Eventually.
Let's get some string though.
What?
Let's order some string.
And then we murder a man.
Moo!
Alright.
Keep upgrading, buddy.
Keep upgrading.
I know where you're going.
Order a cow?
Sounds like a promiscuous website.
Stop moving!
No!
You need to go to the murder... this area.
Come here, come here.
Oh, look, look!
Look, look, look, look!
Something you want to buy!
Come here, come here.
Yeah, yeah.
No!
He knew what it was!
Make him walk the plank.
If I do attack him, will he get angry?
Here we go.
Slowly but surely.
Fine.
We'll leave him for now.
You missed your chance.
I was too excited for him to be standing there.
Walk the plank, me hearties.
But yeah, what did you guys do this weekend?
While I was gone.
I'm gonna say in advance, too.
I know tomorrow's my anniversary.
I don't have much planned, you guys.
I'm really sorry.
It's gonna be kind of... probably... it's kind of disappointing, honestly, because it's like...
my first anniversary, but I have nothing for it.
An ironically made cafe?
TFTI, thanks for the invite.
What the hell?
Wait for you to come back.
There he goes.
Bye!
Went to a made cafe at MGS Con.
Oh, we were gonna make a new shovel.
Went to a convention and got a tattoo in celebration of someone 9 centimeters...
You guys are obsessed with 9 centimeters!
9 centimeters...
Is this like a...
How long is the... I mean...
9 centimeters is plenty?
I'm not shaming.
It's not... it's not... it's not...
how much you have, it's how you use it, right?
That's what they always say.
About any context.
In any sort of context.
It's not how much you have, it's how you use it.
I do not...
use it.
Well then, here are lies.
Don't complain.
I choose to use it for evil.
Now that's just not right.
Awesome stream today, Mint.
I'm jump... I'm walking the plank.
I'm walking the plank!
Oh, now we're finally starting to get hungry a little bit.
And let's make some more...
sticks.
And...
and...
fence.
I didn't mean to do all of it!
Oh my gosh.
Fence.
Oh yeah.
If you were 9cm would you be OK with being in a jar?
Noooo.
I'm a ghost, and I'm not OK with being in a jar.
You know how, like, there's the little ghost canisters...
that everybody threatens to put me into?
I'm not OK with that either.
Thinking more of a cage.
well maybe soon eventually you could put your own Minto in in wherever you like well not within I mean I mean it's you it would be yours I could not stop you but But I would not want to know.
This is not going to happen to Line Up With Ivo.
I had a great time watching some fighting games.
Speaking of, have you ever played a fighting game?
I think I've like very casually played stuff before.
But nothing ever serious before.
I wish the rain would stop.
I wish there was a way I could stop the rain.
Because the rain and the sounds are so loud.
I don't like them.
They make it hard for me to think.
Womp, womp, womp.
Sagu Melon, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
You can turn it down.
I guess you're right.
I'm not used to Minecraft pausing, you know, when you...
Let's see, weather.
Let's take it down to like 45.
Thank you, thank you.
Into the phantom thermals for you bad ghost.
How's that?
Is it still too loud?
Kind of the same.
Mysterious trader, how did you get in there?
He's like, good question.
We can find a beehive!
Hold on.
Guess who's birthday it is.
Mine!
Vic Viper, happy birthday!
New emails look awesome.
Thank you, man.
Thank you!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Vic Viper.
Happy birthday!
20%.
Oh, see, that's better.
Let's also plant some more trees.
Maybe we can get some more...
Actually, I'm just going to turn the overall sound to like 70.
We can do the weather up a little bit more.
Perfect.
The rain is wisps crying because Minto hates us.
Why do you think that?
The trader has two feet of wood between his legs.
The fence?
What do you mean by that?
Thank you so much for the amazing streams.
You're pretty good.
Thank you!
Let's do some bamboo.
What kind of bamboo?
Let's do some bamboo...
and I can plant that...
And we can...
...get that going because that plants well.
We'll replant this like right here, and I am going to keep extending this.
Don't think that just because I put a fence it's like all over.
You know?
In fact...
Huh?
I have a question for you.
When Otacon pisses himself, do you think he changed his pants or he walked around Shadow Moses with pissy pants?
I think he walked around Shadow Moses... with pissy pants.
No, I don't need coal.
I don't need coal!
I want the beehive.
Do I have anymore?
No, I don't have anymore!
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Sir?
I will be acquiring your beehive.
I think... oh, nice, it's already growing.
I think it's quite well known that Otacon doesn't change his pants.
Just kind of goes around...
sopping what... you know?
Throughout all the games?
Every single one.
Mint, please.
He's just a pee guy.
I didn't even ask the question.
Alright, what should we build on our little island?
There was one version of the one block that I saw that I kind of wanted to get.
It had like different islands that you could go to.
I think it was a bedrock version.
What is Bro doing over there?
He is staying out of my way.
He's actually in the very best possible place he could be.
He's staying out of my way.
He is causing no trouble.
I think I can get it.
All the little boys are going to come to me!
What's that thing?
Compost?
I need slabs.
Okay.
Slab.
Compost.
And then we can start putting some stuff in to get bone meal.
Such as...
Ugh.
I can build a cauldron to collect rain?
Is that what that does?
No way.
Wait, I just sold all my iron.
You guys, I just sold... We gotta dig.
The moss!
You're right, the moss.
The moss.
It takes a while with the cauldron.
But right now we're not getting anything.
So...
Might be good.
Mysterious trader new maid cafe employee.
I don't think he's got what it takes.
His head is really big.
His head is huge!
Actually...
Quite is...
He's quite...
He's got quite a noggin.
Hem.
Let's see.
Let's try growing...
I don't want to grow this.
Well, I do.
But...
It's just for decoration mostly, so...
If I put it beehive right here...
Will they come?
Do you hear that?
He's working in there!
He's working!
No flowers?
What do you think I'm doing?
What are you thinking you're doing?
Let me get some more seeds.
There we go, now there's flowers.
More seeds for the compost.
Perfect.
Come on now!
It's fine!
You hear him?
Everybody okay?
We felt the time skip.
Something happened with OBS.
Disconnected real quick.
Alright, starting out a little slow.
Sorry guys, you know, it's been a while since I've played Minecraft.
It's been some time.
But we're getting back into it.
We're getting back into it, baby.
How much was the cauldron?
Ca- ca- cauldron?
Caul... caul... caul...
Caul... ca...
How do you spell cauldron again?
Am I crazy?
Oh, there we go.
No!
97.
You guys...
Don't judge me.
We got raw...
We...
We got it raw.
English is hard, okay?
Nice.
More?
Yeah More, more, more I hear him.
But I think he wants to come out.
I think he wants to come out only when it's daytime.
Okay, whatever.
Instead it's a nice, lovely night.
Unique New York.
You need New York.
Awesome, awesome.
Judgment.
Okay.
We're making... we're cutting through these.
And we're gonna get some honey.
It's gonna be great for your AGO class.
My AGO classes.
Stop!
I... I...
I mean, but truly, ghost is my first language, so...
Are you gonna judge someone whose first language is not English?
For speaking...
Making a mistake in English?
Yes!
You're so mean!
Say something in ghost?
He won't...
You won't understand.
I'll say something, okay.
I'm gonna teach you guys a curse word.
Okay?
I'm gonna teach you guys a bad word.
Ready?
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Eight...
Ten...
11...
12...
13...
14...
15...
16...
17...
19...
20...
21...
22...
23...
24...
25...
26...
28...
27...
29...
30...
34...
35...
36...
47...
48...
50...
55...
68...
39...
40...
41...
45...
46...
44...
48...
Traitor!
We need to get diamonds.
In light of the foul language, I think I need to give you this before you're demonetized.
No, no, no, it's okay!
That word... what?
Anyway...
I'm curious... I don't...
Is it like one of the things in the...
One of the emojis that you can spam in your guild?
Anyway...
Cat bunny word...
What?
Cat
bunny?
What?
Wait...
I'm so confused!
You guys confuse me every day!
I don't know what's going on!
I'm so confused!
Please wrap it up!
I'm sorry!
I don't know!
Move on!
Why am I getting...
Why am I... Why are people...
Why are you getting...
My weeb card!
What?
Not my weeb card!
If I don't have a weeb card, I have nothing left.
If I don't have a weeb card, what even is my identity?
What do I even have?
I need more apples.
We need more apples so we can eat you guys.
Let's put down the plants again.
If I don't have a weeb card, I just have...
I don't even know.
Stink card?
I don't have that either!
You have that.
Don't get it mistaken with me, please.
Thank you.
I have...
Well...
I was gonna say like I have maybe...
A freak card.
Got my freak card on.
Freaky Minto.
Freak phantom card.
If I made freak phantom cards, would you guys want one?
Back...
Way back when I first opened memberships, the first 44...
Because of course it had to be because it's very spooky.
Got the first people that...
First 44 that joined the memberships got a special card.
Maybe...
Freak...
Too much freak.
Not enough phantom.
The V card?
Wait...
Clearly you mean the...
Who's saying V card?
What's wrong with you guys today?
You guys are so freaky.
Um...
But uh...
Maybe if I brought those back and did the same thing.
First 44.
I remember who got the first one and the first one before.
They're sometimes still in the chat.
What do you want?
Is it me?
No.
So jealous of the OGs...
What's there to be jealous of?
What I was thinking was the first 44.
Oh, sorry.
I don't think I finished my sentence.
The first 44...
Would get it...
Their name filled out.
By Watashi.
And then...
But obviously, there would be more.
But the first 44 would be the ones that...
I get it.
With the handwritten.
I don't know.
It's just a thought.
Maybe.
But having freak phantom cards would be kind of fun.
But you already opened memberships.
No, it wouldn't be a membership thing.
It would be...
Oh!
Food, food, food, food!
Oh, I forgot about my food!
Wait, don't steal any of my food!
He literally exploded.
Wait, where is he?
You're okay.
Hmm...
We could get a slime ball.
We could get bone.
We don't need the bone.
We don't need any of this.
Go, go, go.
Go, go.
Please leave.
Please vacate the premises.
Spruce for podzol.
I have spruce though.
What is a podzol good for?
Is this bee ever coming out?
Wait, I don't hear him anymore.
Oh, I hear him.
Okay, okay.
He's still in there.
I hear him.
It's not that the anime fest schedule is out.
Your schedule for the con is packed.
You're telling me.
I know.
It's crazy.
That's why I was just like, oh gosh, if I don't make it.
Crazy, crazy.
It's waiting to jump scare you.
It's a booby.
Okay.
You have an event or two each day.
It's insane.
Yeah, I'm going to still try and put out a schedule for this week.
But I'm going to be basically streaming in between events of the convention.
So it's a little crazy.
But yeah, I'll be there.
And I'll be streaming also.
What was I going to do?
Oh, make a...
We need another pickaxe.
I don't need this guy to leave.
I need to get this guy to get out of my hair.
If I kill him, will he be upset?
Huh?
Dead man tell no tales.
Oh!
Kill the villager.
I got an achievement!
So what did I bet?
I see that means I hadn't killed them before ever.
Make sure to get some rest too.
I will.
Thank you.
That means I never killed him before.
That was my first murder.
I've tasted blood.
Do you think they're going to raise the prices?
You think they're going to get upset?
Oh, we're so close to 500.
That means we might get a new...
We might get a new block.
Please.
Step five.
Alright.
New season.
Nice murder meantime.
Thank you.
What are we...
Oh!
We're on to...
Andesai!
Not counting the baby.
The baby was not murder.
Though...
It could have been.
The baby was a freak accident.
The baby was self-defense.
I can't believe I ran over a baby this morning.
I missed out on getting a meet and greet ticket.
But I'm looking forward to seeing you at VEXPO.
Yeah!
Well, if you go to the Minto meet up.
Which I believe...
Is a...
Sunday...
Afternoon.
Is this one gonna grow back?
Or do I have to plant it?
I think I have to plant it.
I wonder if I can make some...
Bad guys appear.
Let's build out a little bit more.
Let's expand.
Domain...
Expansion!
I'm acting like I watched...
Gojo's Bizarre Adventure.
There we go.
Look at that.
And we're gonna turn this into our pet play area.
This is the pet world.
Right here.
Oh.
Just not that.
Here.
Chup-chup-chup-chup-chup-chup.
They'll have plenty of room to walk...
Probably.
Eventually...
And...
What did I say?
They're all heaven and earth, ateno.
Thank you.
What did I say now?
No I didn't.
You made an area specifically for pet play.
What is... is that weird?
Pet play?
I was thinking... I said the pet play area.
It's a playpen for pets!
Yeah, exactly!
What did I say?
Hey!
I'm just gonna... I'm just...
You guys, this is it.
I'm leaving all my stuff to you.
Goodbye cruel world.
I don't wanna live... I don't wanna live on this planet anymore.
Something, something.
Goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye.
Wait, I need another chest.
But you're not living.
I am in Minecraft.
I don't wanna live in Minecraft anymore.
If I die, I wonder what happens.
Haruka!
Thanks for the gift!
Why does chat know this?
Chat knows a lot of things that I don't really understand.
Dual flip!
Oh!
We're getting some of this other stuff too.
Diorite.
It's Freaky Tuesday.
Please forgive the dehydrated ones.
Again.
I kind of mentioned this somewhat recently.
How like, you know, sometimes when I tell my friends who are completely out of the vtuber sphere.
Just like sometimes things that are said to me or said in chat.
They'll be like...
Oh my god.
Like, girl!
Get out of there, girl!
They'll be like...
Why?
Why do you tolerate this?
And I think my brain is seriously like...
I think I'm just seriously like...
So desensitized to things now.
It's pretty bad.
It's kind of like when you go on Twitter in public and you're just like...
You're so used to seeing...
You know...
Um...
Like...
I don't know...
Anime boobies on your timeline.
You just think it's normal.
Then you go out in public and you're just like...
Oh wait.
This is...
This is not what normal people look at.
You know?
Oh, that's me.
Did someone say boobies?
So it's kind of funny just when I hear their perspective on things.
How they're just like...
What?
What are you doing?
Oh, I thought that said order a ghost!
Wait, a goat?
A pig!
We can get gum powder.
I'm used to seeing people unconscious with blood on them.
Order a ghost!
It's called a Luigi board.
Our own freaky ghost maid?
No.
No, sorry.
That's one of a kind.
Genuine one of a kind.
Huh?
Are you ordering a minto?
Hmm...
I don't think I need anything here.
Maybe the cactus we could try getting.
Um...
How much...
How much of...
Iron?
Oh, I have quite a bit.
Now we can be cooking up.
Whatcha doing over here?
Contemplating?
Look how cute our area is though.
Right?
We got so much nice stuff here.
We don't even need a house.
We're better than that.
And now we're getting clay?
Yeah.
We got clay and stuff too.
What should I build next you guys?
What should I build next?
Oh, my tummy is starting to hurt.
Why is my tummy starting to hurt?
Oh -hoo!
What shaders do you have?
Nod.
Build a big shell.
Oh, we're getting minecraft music again.
Do you like it better without shaders?
See, I like minecraft with shaders.
Next.
But I like it when it's not like...
When it makes like the clouds and everything too realistic, I'm like, no!
I kind of like it better when it's...
You know, the clouds are still like this, but it just adds a little bit of ambient lighting.
Very lightweight shaders.
Yeah, yeah!
It just adds a little bit.
I prefer it a bit cartoony.
Yeah, like there's some that make the grass and everything so realistic.
And I'm like...
Nah, I don't need that.
I just wanna...
You know, I wanna have like... again...
The lighting to have like...
Some pretty colors...
Even sometimes the water...
Oh yeah!
We gotta make our cauldron!
Okay, now...
Now we will be collecting water.
Right here.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright guys!
Very good, very good!
Just trying to think of what are the things I could build.
Let's start...
Throwing more moss into here.
I'm gonna need food soon.
I'm gonna need...
I'm gonna need foo- Bye-bye.
I'm gonna starve in Minecraft!
Chuu!
I wrote a poem...
To immortalize a good friend that I met at Off-Kai.
Okay.
What is a wisp?
I think I saw one run past me just now.
How another could love someone...
Part 1.
Out of FOUR?!
Amelia?
You really put some thought into this.
Out of four?!
Bro's been cooking.
You've been really thinking about this.
Ofukai was a couple months ago.
Part 2.
Seventeen seconds ago, we caught a tweet from her.
Stuff for anyone still at Ofukai.
I couldn't do it though.
But he could.
For I was not the strongest wisp.
He became smaller and smaller down the street.
And I was sure it was destiny.
You really felt so moved.
What's the next part?
What happens next?
What happens next?!
I'm invested now.
Me too!
The suspense!
Don't leave me hanging!
When do they kiss?
I'm kind of shipping them.
I'm not going to lie.
Part 3.
He would win a mint card because he was the strongest wisp.
He would make it from the crowd to the Hyatt.
And of course, he'd win our Oshis offerings.
But ten minutes later, and I was there too.
And... it's on a cliffhanger!
It's on a cliffhanger!
And what?
And what?!
Oh my god.
And then we kissed.
Wait until next month for part 2.
I'm expanding so I can put in more trees too.
It wasn't meant to be now!
It wasn't wispily possible to be a half mile head start.
And I remember that destiny isn't real.
But a few seconds later when I saw him again, he held up his phone.
And he was in the center of her new tweet.
I tagged it.
Oh my gosh.
No, destiny is real!
What's so funny?
I liked it.
That's why it was funny.
You don't laugh at things that you really like?
Did I grab everything I needed from this guy?
That's kind of expensive.
15 iron ingots for a cactus?
Or for 8 cactus?
Okay, get out of here.
I think I laugh too much, you guys.
I think I'm laughing all the time.
That was beautiful, Amelia.
Hopefully next time is your chance to get the sign.
If you really want it.
We laugh and we grow fat here.
True!
Don't mind me just rolling the Chu gacha.
You failed, I'm sorry.
I procrastinated so hard writing this.
I had it done a few weeks ago.
I spent way too much time trying to work up the courage to send it.
I'm glad you liked it.
I hope he does too.
He's probably so honored.
I'm glad you felt so inspired.
No such thing as too much laughter.
Sometimes I worry people will take it the wrong way.
And sometimes I just...
There he goes.
Sometimes I just laugh because I like something so much, you know?
I'm not laughing in like a...
This sucks.
I'm laughing in like a...
Wow.
That was just so great.
I have no words, but I must laugh.
Going to Japan several months after I made Cafe Rex.
I'm looking forward to checking them out.
Yeah!
Have fun, Seymour!
What about the Tutoroo gacha you mentioned a few streams ago?
It's like...
Ultra rare.
One in a million.
I have no words, but I must laugh.
Hehehe.
Uh-oh, you guys.
We need more food.
Okay, let's start planting trees.
Tree time!
One in a mint million.
Exactly.
Grow!
Uh-oh.
Guys, we're going to starve!
We're going to starve!
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Okay, don't panic.
Don't...
Everybody...
Stop panicking.
Stop panicking!
You guys are making me panic, okay?
Stop panicking.
Thank you, thank you.
Bye!
Tutoroo gacha...
Don't even try!
It's too rare!
Oh!
Don't test your luck!
It's too rare!
I'm panicking.
No, you're panicking.
I'm not panicking.
Too...
Oh my god, stop!
Hey!
I've never been more calm.
Let's start.
Okay, apples.
You're the apple of my eye.
My mom said I'm one in a million.
And I'm sure she meant that.
You're just so unique and special.
Possessed to push my lucks.
Get out of here!
You'll never find it!
I'll leave the Tutoroo in one piece.
Stealth camouflage.
You guys, there's no apples.
Don't you...
Why don't you sell food?
Why don't you sell food, mysterious?
Serious?
Traitor?
Why?
We're gonna starve!
Let's just keep digging.
Plant the seeds.
No, I don't have any water!
I can't plant them!
I have no water!
They won't grow!
What's this Wii?
This is always a team play game!
It's...
You guys!
I...
You are me!
We are Wii!
We're a team!
There's no I in team!
It's always been us!
I always consider you part of the team.
We're all together in this.
We're all complicit in any crime.
I am literally Minto.
That's what you said when I possessed your mom last night.
I don't think that made much sense.
I think I...
I appreciate the effort.
I think I could have botched that one.
What I meant to say was...
I think it's dead.
You know what?
I'm not even going to attempt to say what I was trying to say.
The joke...
The bit is dead.
Just like the fans said to Konami, the bit is dead and you're the ones who killed it.
Good one, Minto.
I don't want to hear it from you.
Alright, let's grab another.
Another thing.
Another shovel.
Okay, before I was like, no rain, please.
Anyway, please.
Now I'm like, please rain.
Please rain.
And this is why you're our Oshii.
Why do you have the clown emoji?
There too.
Tyler, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Why do you have the clown emoji?
Gonna starve.
The bees aren't coming out.
If I take this down, do they...
Does it destroy it?
I can't remember.
Okay, nice.
Got lots and lots of bamboo, which means we can make lots of string and we can also make lots of bamboo thingies.
Bamboo.
Block of bamboo.
That's kind of expensive.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
You guys, I can't run anymore.
I'm too hungry.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
Bamboo.
Oh no, no, no.
I want to make more bamboo.
Oh, here.
Oh.
Are we gonna die?
Eat him for sustenance.
The trees do not bear fruit.
The winters are long and cold.
The animals have abandoned us.
I think...
I think this might be it.
Our small journey.
Oh gosh, I really hope it doesn't drop an apple over the edge.
This might be it for us.
Everybody.
An apple.
Sustenance.
We can get more.
Food!
We need water.
Just a little... a little to hold us over.
We can make it.
We can make it together, everybody.
Believe.
And if not...
I've never tried brains before.
Okay, hold on.
Let's plant more trees.
Come on, grow, grow, grow.
Grow, grow, grow, please.
Expand, expand.
There's a first for everything.
I know.
Don't you get like certain parasites from...
How did you get up there?
From eating brains, though?
If I don't make it...
Oh, my gosh.
It's beautiful.
It took forever to grow.
If I don't make it...
Oh, my gosh.
It grew because my body is going to die here.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to die here.
I'm going to move this so it's not under the tree.
Maybe we'll get some actual water so we can grow some pumpkins or something.
Melon, something.
Melon.
It grew you a place to rest.
I want to live.
Please.
Please, grow world.
Just give me some fruit.
Something.
I don't want to die.
Oh, let's plant another tree here.
Just keep planting trees.
One more.
Food fun for hungry ghosts?
But ghosts don't eat food, do they?
Yes, we do!
What do you think the sacrifice is?
You know, people leave offerings and stuff for ghosts!
Because we're hungry!
Hungry ghosts!
I'm sure you'll find a way to survive sooner or later.
Yeah, you've never heard of a hungry ghost before?
It's real.
Hungry ghosts.
You're next, buddy.
You're next.
People leave out... rice... whatever...
Oranges is a popular thing!
Oranges!
Live, Mint!
You have to live!
Wernst... Dortholf... Hunter!
How long do I have to live?
What's a ghost's favorite food?
Boulogne!
That's up for you to decide, Minto.
No water for crops?
We have no water?
I made some sort of progress.
But I'm not rewarded for it.
Actually, I don't know what progress I made.
Can I eat bamboo?
It's sugar, right?
It's kind of the same as sugarcane?
Bulgogi?
I love bulgogi, though.
So good.
You guys are making me hungry.
I had the most mediocre pizza last night.
The travel was hard, I'll be honest.
It was so...
Gosh.
It was like... I think that's why I don't know what day it is.
Because everything was just so long.
Rinblei!
Thanks for the three months!
Boulogne...
What?
Boulognes.
Hope you had fun at MGSK.
I love you.
Thank you!
I did.
It's so much fun.
I hope it happens again next year.
This is the map that if you jump off, you just TP to the top again.
I know one of these maps do that, but don't do that and refill.
Wait.
Okay, let's attempt.
This is for science.
We're doing it.
We're jumping off the edge of the world for science.
For science!
Looks like... It looks like Outer Wilds here.
Do a flip.
Fall into the void!
We did it!
Yippee!
Yay!
The void fed you!
Oh my gosh!
We know the strats.
We know the life hacks.
What you doing down here?
On the death... death walk.
Free food!
More food!
Order a horse.
Order a llama.
When are we getting to the good stuff?
Huh?
Gravel.
Gravel gives us flint.
Maybe we should order some of that.
Do I have enough dirt?
Cauldron has water.
No it doesn't.
We escaped death by dying.
Woohoo!
The pufferfish has water!
Wait, does it count?
Does this count?
Oh!
Wait!
Oh god!
He's just swimming around over there.
I'm gonna take away his life source.
Oh no!
No!
Wait!
Don't!
I can't!
I got it!
I need to live!
Get a second one.
Can I put this in here?
There we go!
Alright!
Wait, if I get a...
How many do I need to make an endless...
An endless...
You know...
Okay, I'm gonna put it...
I'm gonna meticulously put it here.
Okay.
See?
Goodbye.
Now, if he falls off the edge...
I mean...
Two by two for him.
For infinite.
Okay.
Save him?
For what purpose?
For what purpose do we need this guy?
Alright.
Let's do our water...
Right here in the corner.
Right here in the corner!
Okay.
I have to be careful about...
About this though.
Okay.
Oh!
No!
Let me...
Let me cook.
Let me cook!
What?!
You need a floor, yah?
What do you think I'm doing?
Alright, there's our floor.
There's our floor.
Ah-hah!
Water!
How sweet water!
Sweet water...
Sweet water!
Water!
Let's plant!
Oh my gosh, we're finally gaming.
Let's make a hole.
Alright, Chet, who's volunteering?
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to hit you.
Are you okay?
No!
He raised his prices!
I didn't murder him.
He went down with the ship.
As a good captain should.
If you make a big enough pond, you can fish.
True!
Very good!
Let's put this... let's move this guy.
Can I fish here?
In this thing?
Or is it too small?
Man, I love fishing.
You can fish in any size pond.
Oh, no way!
Alright, perfect.
Now, let's keep... let's keep one blocking.
I do kind of want to...
Maybe go down here.
We should start making... we should start building like a downstairs area as well, I think.
I think we should start building a...
A downstairs area.
Where do I want to build it?
Oh, wait.
I can put more of the flowers down too.
We'll never... we'll never get these bees but that's okay.
Hmm...
Put your tools away just in case.
You don't have any faith in me?
I go down when you can go up?
Well, I do want to build one thing below.
I do... below... below I do want to build one thing.
And hold on, I will do it.
No!
Because I kind of want to build a thing below the... the one block.
Oh gosh, it's so scary though.
Wait, where's the one block?
Okay, this one...
Okay.
Here.
That... nope, just kidding.
That one.
Right!
That's the one block.
I believe.
Right!
That's the one block.
I think.
Oh yeah, we got water!
Finally!
It's okay.
Uh-oh.
Am I gonna drown?
There we go.
Oh!
We're okay!
We're...
We're okay.
Everything is all good.
I even have dirt to replace it.
Perfect.
Now...
I will feel less...
Nervous...
About...
Oh!
Oops.
About...
Uh...
Getting stuff here.
Hungry Ghost Festival is actually a holiday here.
In Hong Kong.
Happening next month.
I'll remember to leave you some leftover offering.
Yes!
Thank you!
That's exactly what I'm talking about!
Thank you so much.
Maybe people don't know about Hungry Ghost.
I think we need more food.
A.K.A.
It might be time to...
Send me over...
I'm going over the edge a little bit, you guys.
Might be time to...
Send me over the edge.
I don't know why August is such a haunted month.
Thank you!
Back to the infinite void.
Not again!
Yes again!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Again!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Because summer vacation?
Maybe.
There's so much to live for.
I'm not even alive!
But I'm glad I have so much to be dead for.
I'm so glad I'm dead.
Even though it's so much like being alive, I think.
Just like...
A little extra stuff.
You know?
It's hard to explain.
So much to be unalive for.
Ha ha ha ha!
You seen that fun with it?
Yeah!
I have a pretty good time.
Even the dead can't escape taxes.
That's what I'm saying.
I think it's so similar to being alive.
But you know...
When are you guys coming out?
I hear you in there.
And when are these guys gonna grow?
There's taxes in the afterlife?
Oh buddy...
I don't know how to tell you this but...
I said it's pretty similar to...
Ha ha ha ha!
I don't want to say real life, because I feel like my life, even though it's the afterlife, it's still real life.
So... what is it?
Oh no, I'm feeling the existentialism again happening.
It's your reality.
Yeah.
It's my reality.
I googled how to free myself from both life and death.
Oh, did I?
Oh no, just kidding.
But now, being a ghost is pretty dandy, I would say so.
Is this the real life?
Or... is this just fantasy?
I'm starting to get sleepy.
We're almost at 2000 blocks.
When will we get an animal?
Oh wait, the animal's right here.
Chat's full of them.
I know.
What the...
Where's the... pickaxe?
Meow.
Did I get... oh no, there's some iron.
And sticks.
Meow, where's the...
Oh, I need three.
World of Darkness lore.
Ghosts live in a reflection of the living world called the Shadowlands.
And they do have to pay ghost taxes.
Yeah, why would I make that up?
Why would I make up ghost taxes?
Pickaxe.
It's death and taxes, not death or taxes.
Why'd you spawn in there?
I want the trial key.
I want to know what that is.
I'm so curious.
Enzo Mancini.
Enzo...
Enzo my man.
Would you rather be a ghost who can't haunt or a maid cafe...
Oh, sorry, a maid.
Oh, I think the music's so good.
Oh.
Or a maid that can't clean.
I love haunting though.
I'm haunting you right now.
Do you want me to not haunt you anymore?
If you don't want me to haunt you anymore, I get it.
It's a little freaky.
It's not everybody's thing.
I'll stop.
I'll stop taking your life floors.
I'll stop haunting you.
Don't worry.
Actually, I don't clean.
I don't clean very well.
So you're like, which would you want?
Which would you want?
And I'm like, well, I'm already...
It's kind of already currently one or the other.
I can't clean very well.
You guys.
Okay.
It's, it's a, it's, it's called being a maid cafe maid.
It's called being a maid cafe maid where.
Where it just I, I, I, I'm, I'm like serve in the cafe.
I don't really do much of anything else.
Can you cook?
Well, I mean like there's like chefs that to that at the.
Yeah.
There's people who do that.
Like, I serve!
I'm serving all day, every day.
And you guys are wisps.
You're also my goshijinsama and ojonsama.
Oh, what happened?
Why did I shrink?
What happened to me?
That was kind of freaky.
You can draw some cool stuff on Omurice.
Yeah!
I'm serving.
Can you slay though?
Slay!
She's the Van Gogh of Ketamjoys.
Why is the potato taking so long?
Maybe I need the pumpkin instead.
Pumpkin seed.
Wait, I have a couple of pumpkin seeds.
Let's just do everything.
Oh, but for the pumpkin, I need sugar and stuff like that too, don't I?
Wait, it's melon.
The melon can just grow!
Baby core, thanks to the gifted!
You need to go muy muy cute.
Okay.
I'm looking.
I'm looking at the seed.
Oh, maybe it's intimidated if I'm holding this, right?
Oishiku nare!
Muy muy cute!
I think it grew a little.
Do I have any bone meal?
It grew!
Micmac!
Thanks to the gifted!
Maybe I can get some more.
Nope.
That's it.
Oh, yes.
More.
Someone grew taller.
It's me!
I'm a whole whopping 10 feet now.
Try calling me small.
We're so close to 2,000.
Wait, no.
I was right the first time.
There we go.
10 feet, imagine.
I'm your giantess Vtuber.
Actually, what?
Giantess would be like...
They're like skyscraper size, right?
Oh, 2,000!
New recipe.
Just check your recipe book.
Huh?
What did I make?
I can't...
Did I grab something?
No.
They don't like give you any sort of like...
Achieve anything...
Any bonuses for when you like hit certain things.
It's so sad.
They're just...
Yeah, giantess are usually like super duper...
Yeah, 10 feet is Amazonian.
Yeah, I think so.
And then like a giantess is like the size of a...
Like a skyscraper, right?
Like a tall building.
I can be that.
Free-fi-fo-fum.
Have you guys ever noticed that my sock is a little transparent?
Have you ever noticed?
Where's my new sock?
On my socks.
On my skirt.
There's something...
Okay.
I don't think I've ever showed this to you guys before.
I want to show you something kind of interesting.
Wait, I took this picture...
Actually, no.
I'll just post it on Twitter later.
Actually, I wonder if I could do it right now.
Give me a second.
I wonder if I could do it right now.
If I could show you right now.
One second.
It might take me a second though.
Oh, wait.
No, I don't think I can.
Wait, hold on.
I don't think I can.
No, I don't think I can.
No!
Wait, maybe I can.
What the heck is she talking about?
I'm gonna see, I'm gonna see.
Yes, you can.
I can do anything I put my mind to, maybe.
Maybe.
Hold on, hold on.
I wonder if it'll work.
Oh my gosh, I think it's working.
Wait a second.
Putting my mind in the bubble.
Look at this.
It's kind of amazing.
So basically...
I don't wanna...
alert anybody, but I'm kind of stripping.
I don't wanna alert anybody, but I'm kind of stripping right now.
But you'll see.
Alerted?
It's so...
It's so cool.
I hope YouTube doesn't get mad at me.
I discovered this the other day.
It's so cool.
Don't get mad at me, YouTube, okay?
Don't get mad at me, YouTube.
One second.
What's going on?
One second, one second, one second.
Sorry.
Now...
I discovered this the other day and now I'm like...
I'm like...
It's so fun.
You'll see.
In a second.
It's kind of scandalous.
Wait a second.
One second.
You'll see.
It's kind of weird because I'm a ghost though.
Look.
This is the longest second of my life.
You guys, look.
I can have...
I can take off my...
Oh la la.
What if one day I just streamed without my skirt?
You'd never know.
How scandalous it is.
Easy, breezy, beautiful cover girl.
Wait.
Why did it change from a leaf to a block?
Oh my god, redstone!
Woohoo!
I thought the whole point of working from home is that pants are optional.
You're exactly right.
But...
You know...
I can't be off the clock for...
My master, my mistress...
I can't be...
I can't be so lazy.
Oh!
Wait, are we gonna be able to enchant stuff?
When am I gonna get a sheep?
Wait, that means we might be closer to diamonds.
What was the goal again?
Of the one block?
To defeat the ender dragon.
I think that's still the goal.
Haven't worn pants in days.
Love work from home.
Oh...
Oh, nice.
Melon seeds...
We can get a sponge, but what would we use a sponge for?
Hmm...
If you have 12 strings, you can make a bed.
No way!
I have 9!
Wait, we have a bamboo, right?
Bamboo can make string.
String...
Can we not make string?
I thought you could make string.
Am I crazy?
Oh, stripped.
Just like me.
Break cobwebs.
Well, we don't have any cobwebs.
Bamboo makes paper.
No!
I think...
The sugar can makes the paper.
Hmm...
Making string is in mods.
Oh, really?
I always thought.
That you could make string too.
Oh my god, wait.
I was gonna say this is gonna fill up, but...
We don't need it anymore.
We do need...
Just a little bit more string though.
Yeah, you useless.
You're useless to me.
You're useless.
Come here.
Don't run from me.
Where is the aim?
There we go.
Don't bully.
I wasn't.
I was sending him home.
Duh.
Useless.
Hmm...
Sometimes I wish I could just...
Dig forever and not like...
Think about anything.
Wait, so since we have nothing else.
What about like enemies?
Do these guys not spawn either?
Oh my god!
Hallelujah!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, is this thing dead now?
Or will it spawn another melon?
It'll regrow?
Perfect!
Our little island is so cute.
Isn't it?
I love our little island.
I'm gonna grow a jungle.
Over here.
I don't know if these need more room.
Hmm...
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm just like wishing there was more...
That would spawn though.
Like before when I played it.
They would like give you stuff...
Every so often or like...
Animals would spawn or...
Maybe I need to play a different...
Version of it.
Everything's so different.
Like I feel like this is a little too...
Like I don't have any animals.
Mobs only spawn 24 plus blocks...
Away.
So if you make a lit...
Grass platform out...
Cows might spawn.
Oh!
Let's try that then.
I don't know how far...
Out I actually am but...
Hmm...
Make the platform bigger?
Okay.
Oh I was like what is that?
What is that floating away?
Oh.
I think we're gonna have to start...
Using other materials.
Oh yeah!
This thing grew so quickly!
Let's see.
We might need to start using other...
Materials.
Might be time.
I'm gonna put the sand away so I don't accidentally...
Place it and be stupid about it.
Ummm...
Let's just put down some oak planks.
Wait I want some more dirt first.
So it's a little more cohesive.
Wait are we not gonna get dirt anymore?
Uh oh.
Oh we got some dirt!
You'll get hostile mobs.
Yeah yeah no worries!
Only spawn on...
They do only spawn on the grass!
Okay.
Alright.
Then we'll have to build out.
Autobots build out!
Okay.
Just a little bit more.
Oops wrong thing.
Little bit more!
Hmm.
I think the biggest pain is switching between...
The different things.
You know what I mean?
Let's also start cooking some of this...
Uh...
Gold!
So we can sell it!
And dirt!
So we can build it!
Choo!
Okay nice!
And light it up baby!
Light it up!
Baby!
Umm...
Uh...
You!
And...
Uh...
What's it called?
Torch!
Feels so weird playing Minecraft again.
Even though it's like not actual Minecraft.
Feels so weird.
Even like...
Touching the game again in some capacity.
Since I haven't played it in so long.
I think...
I think my brain riot was replaced with...
Bloons honestly.
Also...
It's kind of...
You know it's hard to play Minecraft.
I know some people prefer solo but...
It's hard...
It's hard when like...
Do you need string?
Turtle scoot!
It's hard playing by yourself though.
You know?
Have you been on the Beat Shoujo server recently?
I'll be honest.
I haven't been on since I...
Went that first time.
It's just...
It's just uh...
Uh...
I feel a little awkward about it.
I'm just like...
I don't know if I'm...
I feel awkward like building in there.
Anti-social minthos.
I can't!
I'm sorry!
I'm so anti-social!
Haunting the server.
You're welcome there.
Just go.
They haven't made me feel unwelcome.
You know?
Not in any ways at all.
It's just you know me.
Being like...
Is it okay?
Also all the mods do kind of...
Freak me out.
There's so many.
But maybe I should just...
Go in some time off stream and...
Um...
Try and get used to it a bit more.
Hmm...
VSMP streams.
Yeah but I was invited to that.
So...
And I'm not gonna be like...
Let me in!
Are they...
I don't even know if they're still playing.
Are you winning your block game?
I think so.
I think we're winning.
Yeah.
Oh.
Minecraft music.
Bees work.
Rain falls.
Need more dirt.
How far is 24 blocks out you think?
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Nine.
Ten.
Eleven.
Twelve.
Thirteen.
Fourteen.
Fifteen!
Oh shucks.
Hahaha.
Uh oh.
Yeah we're gonna have to make it...
We're gonna... We won't fill this in.
We're just gonna have to make it...
Skinny.
Skinny legend.
We get barely...
Any dirt anymore though.
Oh!
I say that and they start giving...
You know what?
It's funnier than 24 blocks.
I'm not gonna...
Oh my gosh.
I'm not gonna say the joke.
I think I know.
But you can say it.
You guys don't guess in the chat.
Twenty five.
Good one boys.
Hahaha.
Okay.
How much more dirt do we have now?
Ten dirt!
And we have none in here, right?
Oh no.
Oh shucks.
Maybe I should steal some from over here.
Oh come on!
What
do you buy with gold?
Nothing?
Okay.
All my iron.
I lost everything!
I can't even...
I
lost all my new dirt!
I lost...
I lost it all.
You still have us?
All for a bit of dirt.
We're going back to the stone age with this one.
I know!
Oh my god.
Let's get our wooden pickaxe.
Not even stone age.
Wait.
Can I make stone?
Oh we can.
We can make stone.
Stone.
You're so cute.
I like your scent so much.
Why are you super chatting me very?
What's wrong with you?
You paid for dinner!
So?
You lent me cash!
Cash!
No gold!
Huh?
Nothing of use.
Why can't they sell dirt?
I can't even get the redstone.
I don't think I put any of the redstone.
Nope.
I didn't put a single redstone away.
Oh my gosh you guys.
Are we going to be able to work like this?
We're going to have no tools.
They're giving us barely any iron.
At least we can get these.
Just a minor setback.
We'll make it back guys.
Believe.
Believe it.
Oh my god.
We don't even get the...
Oh more iron.
More iron.
Okay more iron.
Okay we're going to start cooking.
We're going to start cooking that iron up.
Let's start.
Iron's back on the menu baby.
Of course it is.
You can make dirt out of oak saplings.
No way.
I lost all my saplings though.
Wait what?
Since when?
I guess I've never needed to make so much dirt before.
When could you do that?
Since when?
Is that a mod?
Is that special?
Is it for this one block?
Oh my god.
We're back to 11 dirt.
Maybe only in one block.
I think I lost all my torches too.
Infinite dirt.
I just wanted to close it up.
Monsters don't worry.
Don't worry.
Did I lose all my coal?
Why was I holding onto everything?
What's wrong with me?
I didn't put a single thing in here.
Oh here's some coal.
Torch.
There we go.
You are eepy.
That is true.
I'm very eepy.
Maybe the eepiest ghost in the wild wild west.
Alright.
Now while that works.
Sorry I'm late to stream.
No.
Why would you apologize?
Giving the last presentation of my time as an undergrad.
Finally I have my biomedical engineering degree.
Oh my god.
You're so smart.
Congratulations.
Cece McShaggy.
That's the funniest name.
Dr. Cece McShaggy.
Congrats.
Biomed.
Why are you watching me?
You watch me to make yourself feel better right?
You're just like god at least I'm not as dumb as her.
What a dumb.
She's like a pile of rocks.
I get it.
I know.
Congrats fellow STEM major.
So.
Smart people do not interact.
Do not watch me.
Do not pay attention to me.
I don't want your judgement.
They're like, did you see that she couldn't even spell cauldron.
She tried getting the dirt.
It fell into the void.
What a bozo.
I've been watching for years.
It's too late.
Thank god I'm an idiot.
Let's rise up.
STEM majors can't spell either.
Maybe I am a genius.
I do have a genius emote.
Guess I should leave then.
No, no.
You're right at home.
Hello fellow dummies.
My fellow idiots.
We gather here today.
In joyous.
Celebratory.
Extravaganza.
As we grieve.
Our fellow.
Smarties.
For they are too smart.
And therefore must be.
Executed.
Time to drain my brain cells.
From my oshi.
Yeah.
Get stupid.
You should be a little stupid around your oshi though.
Right?
It's kinda like when you're around your crush.
You gotta be a little stupid around your oshi.
Mint does make me stupider.
Then I'm doing my job.
You should lose some brain cells.
You know?
But I'm stupid already?
Then it's working.
Don't worry Mint.
I've been working in STEM as a testing engineer for a few years now.
There's plenty of idiots here.
Sounds personal.
Sounds like...
How many...
How far are we out?
Let's see.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Nine.
Ten.
Eleven.
Twelve.
Thirteen.
Fourteen.
Fifteen.
Sixteen.
Seventeen.
Eighteen.
Nineteen.
Twenty.
Why did
he have to appear right there at that time?
At that moment?
Oh my god.
Scared the...
Scared me so bad.
We can order a cow though.
We can order a cow.
Soon.
I think.
We just gotta get more gold.
And we gotta be able to mine it.
Where was I?
I lost cow.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Nine.
Ten.
Eleven.
Twelve.
Thirteen.
Fourteen.
Fifteen.
Sixteen.
Seventeen.
Eighteen.
Nineteen.
Twenty.
Twenty-one.
Twenty-two.
Twenty-three.
Twenty-four!
Twenty -five.
You can make infinite dirt but you'll lose gravel.
Just make coarse dirt and you can get two more dirt by breaking it.
I know too much about Minecraft.
Or I can turn these...
Look!
It's our jungle tree!
I can turn these into dirt.
I was hoping for another jump scare.
What are you?
A sadist?
Those people that watched were masochists.
Are you a sadist or a masochist?
Which are you?
Why not both?
I'm a normal person.
Both?
Really?
Pull time!
For my Oshi I can M.
That's so...
That's so real.
It's probably the realest thing...
PUMPKINS!
Probably the realest thing you've ever said.
Put this pumpkin away.
I work for a cybersecurity company and our business partner was pretty stupid last Friday.
You're smarter than Cloud Strife.
Thank you Devlin for the ego boost.
Thank you.
Let's grab some more dirt.
More dirt.
Feels good.
Hmm.
Normally I'd M but your suffering is very entertaining.
Oh so it's only...
It's only when it's me...
Okay.
Dirt Phantom.
What do you want?
What do you want from me?
Do you also like to see my suffering?
I like to see your suffering too.
I don't think we can be amorous with no brain cells.
True?
Where are the cows?
Moo if you're a cow.
Moo.
What's the chat summary?
Oh, I think it's time.
I think we can actually make some... yeah.
Let's remake our stuff.
Iron pickaxe is most important.
Go away stone.
And our iron axe.
And our iron shovel.
Everything stone be gone.
What are we in the stone age?
There we go.
It's so swift.
Happy to be here for three months.
Happy to have you for three months.
Thank you.
Nice.
Now we're starting to get the good...
We're getting our stuff back everybody.
Minor setback.
But we're getting everything back.
Nothing is spawned yet.
Do you think I need to go further away?
Here.
Actually I'm going to build out a little over there.
Okay.
Like this?
Give them a little bit more.
Mean comment to balance out all the nice comments.
Well, what's the mean... what you're saying?
Mint, you...
You...
You have a crooked tooth.
You have a fang.
I... I...
You see it?
I...
Crab's tooth.
I have
one fang.
I...
You see it?
One block of mintcraft.
Did anyone make that joke yet?
Glad you made up a safe window.
Thanks road.
Cute fang.
Thank you.
I love deformed teeth.
I love teeth that are messed up.
It's my favorite thing.
You're too close to save me.
Sorry.
Barry finally messaged me back.
I don't know if I can say it though.
I'm lagging a little.
I don't think I can say it.
The special thing.
She was like...
I was like, what's the special thing I did?
She's like, did I say something like that?
You were cute.
There's something else.
But I can't say it.
What happened to the right fang?
I never had two fangs.
I always just had one fang.
Because my teeth grew weird.
And I died weird.
Guys, I love my one tooth.
I love my one messed up tooth.
Why are you weird?
Wow, weirdo.
Takes one to know one.
That sounds like a self report.
The tooth is real.
Oh, Minecraft music.
Snaggle tooth.
Got them.
Absolutely.
You guys, when do they start?
Little cow.
Cow, cow, cow.
Where are you?
You, you, you.
Little cow.
Cow, cow, cow.
Why won't you come home?
Home, home.
It's still not grass?
It needs to be grass.
Can't just be dirt.
If I do this, will it happen faster?
Ms. Mint Phantom, what's the pink thing?
Oh, I can't use it.
Check the bio.
We're in the plains, baby.
I got a pink thing.
Umm... while I at MGS con.
But not at MGS con.
Just while I was there, you know?
I can spawn?
Okay.
It's gonna spawn.
Guys, just hold...
I won't end stream until we get a cow.
Where is the cow?
Oh!
Step 7.
2500.
What do we get now?
Wow.
Where's the diamonds?
Why don't we get any diamonds?
We're getting deep sleep with no diamonds yet.
Emeralds.
Nice.
Was the pink thing one more brain cell for chat?
I need it more than you.
What can we buy?
Really enjoyed hearing your MGS CON stories.
So happy your brain round is thriving more than ever!
Yeah!
Glad you were able to get home alright and good luck with the upcoming CON.
Thank you Ms. Consanity!
Thank you so much...
String!
What were we trying to get string again for?
What were we trying to make?
We needed 12 string to make something.
What was it?
Oh a bed!
Huh.
I don't have so much iron though.
Should I waste it?
You think?
You think I should waste it?
We don't technically...
Diamond!
Oh my god!
Wait what do you sell?
What do you buy?
Single diamond!
Yeah!
Keep growing!
I'm gonna... I'm gonna make more room for activities.
Where's my hole?
Hole?
Here.
I'll just make a wooden one.
Your Metal Gear brain rot is contagious.
I know it is.
Oh wait.
How do I...
How do I get more seeds?
Mint's life depends on finding a floating cow.
The stakes have never been higher.
How do I make more seeds?
Oh the crafting.
You use the slices.
Okay.
Let's let this grow.
Let's let that grow.
And then...
Okay.
I only have...
This is as much iron as I have.
Thank you for your business.
Let's see.
Bed.
Oh.
Whoa.
One.
Two.
You guys, we don't have enough!
Wait.
Bed.
There's some in the chest.
There is...
Oh, you're right.
Thank you.
Two.
One out of eleven diamonds to go.
Also, ten out of a thousand.
A thou...
Out of a thousand, what?
Gerson.
Welcome to my bookshop.
Thank you.
Bed.
Wait.
Oh!
Whoa!
Bed.
The Paris Olympics is starting this Friday.
It is?
Good night.
I don't know the last time I watched the Olympics.
I kind of want to watch them go swimming though.
In that nasty river.
I don't want to watch it happen.
And be like, eww, I can't believe they're doing this, for real.
They approve the eSports Olympics?
What's the eSports Olympics?
They should compete in Metal Gear.
No, there are people that are actually insane with Metal Gear.
I know one of the guys.
His name is Apache.
And he can literally play the game blindfolded.
He can beat Metal Gear Solid 3 blindfolded.
I don't know how people can do that.
At MGSCon, he did a run where it was all invisible enemies.
And he was still able to know where they were.
Their entire life, training to swim in poopy water.
I saw that, it was crazy.
It was so crazy.
How is that possible?
How do you know where they walk?
It was so crazy.
The fact that you can do a blindfolded 2 is just...
The whole thing blows my mind.
Speedrunners are so cool.
Get out of here!
Go, go, go, go, go, Nasty, go.
I have got what I wanted from you.
I need nothing else.
I need no more from you.
Diamond!
2024 Olympic gold medal for bloons.
Minto.
I want to play bloons because I want to play the maps.
I saw some people created the Minto map, so...
Minto, my Oshii.
Bogey here, back home after being stranded for a while.
No!
Got a new job, getting ready for my courses and still watching my Oshii.
Thank you for sticking around.
The silliest coolest ghost.
Thank you for sticking around too!
Good luck with your not being stranded anymore and...
More diamond.
This much diamond has never happened to me before.
I watched games done quick.
That's my Olympics.
The gaming Olympics.
I love gaming Olympics.
Who is that MGS streamer player that would do MGS3 runs in the monkey mask with the torch?
I don't know.
Does anybody know?
Doki is not here to steal.
Why would she even?
I asked her...
I asked her for...
I was like, can I get on your server?
I was like, I want to play on your server, Doki.
So maybe one day you'll randomly see me if you play on there.
And I'd still like to make my own.
I haven't given up that idea.
I just...
I think...
I think for a lot of things I might wait until after the Patreon is over because that takes up currently so much of my mental bandwidth.
So...
But eventually in the future.
Having it.
That server is a war and a half.
Wait, why?
What's going on in there?
All I saw was like some...
She sent me...
Like it showed up in my timeline too but Doki was just like...
Apparently we got married on the server.
Property value skyrocketing?
Well, I get exclusive property.
I get an exclusive space.
But...
Zaito!
Thank you for the...
50 gifted!
Thank you so much!
It was a beautiful wedding.
Why wasn't I invited to my own wedding that apparently happened?
How many people went to this wedding?
What were my vows even?
You were there kind of.
She knows.
Doki is the one who sent it.
She sent it to me.
Doki was just like...
Look at this.
I was like...
What's going on in your server?
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh my gosh.
The grass is taking so long to spread.
The gooners gooning.
I recently became a big fan.
Thank you!
Your videos help after a long day of work.
Thank you.
I can't wait for more content.
Logan!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
There's like 70 people.
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you so much!
I hope you had a good stream.
I just realized.
I gotta put some stuff away.
We don't want...
Wow!
I have so much lapis.
We don't want another incident.
Murphy!
Thanks for the five gifted!
I was like...
It's the cult leader on the Doki SMP.
Doki, thanks for the gifted.
Thank you.
Oh Orca.
I would say never change.
But also...
That's what I'll say about that.
Please change immediately.
All right.
Let's see.
Let's make our seeds.
We might...
I wonder if we'll have enough to...
Enough diamond...
To...
Where is the guy?
To get a cow.
Where is he?
Oh!
What are you doing up there?
A cow!
Wait, six.
Six.
I think we have six, you guys.
I think we have six.
Wait.
Should we wait?
Okay.
You guys.
We could cheat mode and I can end stream right now.
Or...
We can wait for the grass.
No.
Stay with us.
I'll see you tomorrow.
With all my exciting things that I have and have not.
I hope we'll see you on Doki's server.
That'd be really fun.
Yeah.
I'll ask you questions.
I'll ask her again about it.
Wait for grass.
I'm kind of tired, though, you guys.
Okay.
We'll wait for the grass a little bit longer.
What's tomorrow?
My anniversary.
I'll have been streaming for one whole year.
As of tomorrow.
Tomorrow.
I finally get to celebrate my one-year anniversary.
I never got to celebrate it before I left all those years ago.
One whole year.
Never got to celebrate it.
So, you know...
Better late than never.
Maybe.
Because I came back on the same day that I graduated.
Right?
And now...
So it's just like I picked up when I left off.
Kind of.
12 months total.
Non-consecutive.
Yeah, pretty much.
Yeah, it's kind of crazy.
Glad we can now.
Yeah, I know, right?
I'm glad we can now.
I do.
I'll make sure.
I'll try to make it fun.
Even though, like I said...
Sorry.
I wish I could offer you guys more.
I wish anything was ready.
I wish... I wish...
I wasn't so slow and bad at stuff.
So I'm really sorry.
I feel...
Quite...
Guilty about it.
I probably shouldn't have gone to the convention.
I should have...
I should have taken the time to...
To get everything ready.
And stuff.
Ooh, more sand.
Wait, did I lose my sand before?
No, I still have the sand.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, what the hell?
Get out of my bed, you freak!
Why are traitors laying in my bed?
Get out of my bed!
It's me.
Don't apologize.
I'm so keen.
What do you mean by that?
You had fun at the con.
It was worth it.
Anti-negative thoughts beam.
Get out of my bed!
Wait!
Oh my gosh!
We lost the cow!
All we want for you to do at your anniversary is hang out with you and watch you sing funny ghost songs.
Well, all my VODs are like... privated, right?
My old VODs.
So if you haven't seen those before...
Um...
Be prepared, I guess.
Be prepared!
It's gonna be bad.
You're gonna see baby Minto...
Long, long ago.
If most of my friends weren't all taken up by NSFW...
Come
on.
Sometimes you guys just, uh...
Chat says the darndest things.
From the MC Wedding Cameraman, it's an honor to know you heard about it.
I kneel.
I saw it on Twitter.
I did see it.
Um... I'd send an akasuba to tell you how proud I am to watch you doing all these conventions and being the best that you can be.
Keep it up.
You guys have... I mean, your name is literally a kinky cadaver.
Like, you but... Seriously, I think we need to bring shame back a little bit.
I think we need a little bit more shame in our lives.
Let's see.
Let's cook this.
And let's make a new pickaxe.
It's barely... It's growing at a snail's pace, you guys.
Absolute snail's pace.
Shame, shame.
So says Freak Phantom.
King Shaming is my king... king?
Lulu-kachu!
Welcome to membership.
We appreciate all that you do, mint combo ghostie.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
That was the flower girl.
There's a flower girl!
Yeah, let's try widening it a little bit.
Let's plump her up.
Oh look, it's spreading more.
Alright, more.
More grass!
More grass.
Does it grow at night?
Grass grows at night.
Touching grass is...
Okay.
Question.
If someone touches grass...
Would you consider that normie behavior?
Even if it's like...
Yes.
Right?
Like if someone has a hobby...
And it involves touching grass, I believe that's normie behavior.
Moo.
Not really.
What do you mean?
Do they do it voluntarily?
Yeah.
Also a library of fanfics.
I want to write one.
Oh my god, Tuesday!
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you so much!
What the heck?
Yay, we leveled up!
Like if someone's...
Having a life equals normie...
That's how I feel.
What if it's like a weirdo hobby?
What's a weirdo hobby?
Cause like...
You can't shame me.
I have no shame.
I ship Volgen and Jan Ros.
Brave.
You're so brave for admitting that.
VTubing?
No, like... Okay.
Like say your hobby...
Say your hobby is running, right?
Like you run.
But like you care really deeply about like stats and...
Like the nerdy side of things.
Does that still...
But that's still considered a normie hobby, right?
Taxidermy?
Poor Mint is too far gone.
Still normie, just lame.
Aries, thank you for three months!
It's athletic.
Right!
Fitness equals normie!
I believe that too.
Thank you guys for justifying me.
I feel so justified right now.
I can't stand hearing these bees and they're not doing anything.
They're acting like they're so busy in there.
Like leave!
Get out!
Asking the least normie chat.
I don't know.
I feel like...
Sometimes I'm like...
Why do...
People that like aren't as deranged as me watch me.
You know?
Like I feel like I appear...
Or rather like...
You wouldn't...
You wouldn't understand.
Unless you're like on the level, right?
You're fun?
I like the chaos.
You just don't get the nuanced weird?
No, no, no.
Still nor...
Athletic is normie.
One year Annie!
Oh my god!
She already owes eight months!
Sent right now cause can't watch tomorrow.
Thank you!
Thanks for...
Thank you for still being around!
Dorky and cute.
Any hobby is a normie hobby if you're casual enough.
You think so?
Sailor Moon!
Thanks for three months!
Two!
Oh!
Thanks, Sehi!
You always brighten my day mint.
Thank you!
Am I your powerful and passionate otaku?
I don't have the power to do the same.
You do!
What are you talking about?
Everybody has the power.
You...
Have the power.
Just...
Do it!
Just be into the...
Just like the things that you like a normal amount.
Or sometimes an abnormal amount.
That's all.
Where is he again?
Oh my god!
No way!
Why does he keep spawning up there?
I can confidently say that you have made me more deranged over the years.
Thank you!
Just want to celebrate with you.
Don't beat yourself up.
Merch, etc.
are just bonuses.
What's more important is spending time with Minto.
Guys, you're gonna make me cry.
Come here, sweet child.
What do you have to sell for me?
A donkey.
Guys, we can get a cat!
Bring me a cat.
Farm villagers.
Order a mob.
Nice.
I just got back from my normie hobby.
Drinking a liter of beer and guzzling Glizzy and then passing out for two hours.
Can you moe-moe-cune my meal?
You already ate it!
The music is a paid actor.
The magic is gone!
Yeah, what kind of Glizzy?
Ten out of ten hobby.
What a freak.
Gosh I thought I was a freak.
Your hobby is Glizzies?
I think it'd be kinda fun to learn how to do the...
How to do the uh...
What's the word?
You know how like there's hot dog eating contest?
That was my grandmother's birthday so I made her baked Alaska.
She's a real hot dog.
What's a baked Alaska?
And torched the meringue right in front of her.
Very normie, but now I get to spend the rest of the night with Mint.
What about your grandma?
Don't worry about being too slow.
We're not providing enough for us.
Every stream with you is a blast.
We're glad to be able to hang out with you.
Mint, love.
Thank you.
Grandma's gone to bed.
Granny's getting scammed.
Ice cream cake which you torch the top of.
That sounds awesome.
Ice cream covered in whipped cream and then baked or torched.
Look at you guys.
It's getting closer.
Soon.
Soon, soon, soon.
And we have some...
melon for food.
Did you guys ever believe that if you ate the seeds it would grow inside you?
Like a tree?
I'll be honest.
I purposefully ate them.
Yes.
No, I was normal.
Every kid believes that.
But I think too much seed...
in an amount is poisonous.
Or was it a puppet?
Can't remember.
That's understandable too.
Well, how about now?
If you eat a seed, will it grow inside you?
I think it might...
Well, maybe the stomach acids.
I think it could a little bit though.
I still believe that.
That's what I'm saying.
Just take an antacid and then eat the seed.
And it'll grow.
Probably.
It needs sunlight.
What?
But seeds are buried in the ground.
Why does it need sunlight?
My tummy is nice and warm.
They just need a warmth and love.
To be cared for.
Take an antacid.
No acid in your tummy.
Believe?
You mean they don't?
Take like 50 tums.
Or something.
Just down the whole bottle.
Eat the seed.
Wham bam.
Thank you ma'am.
You got yourself a watermelon.
You're a proud parent.
Of a watermelon.
Is that safe?
Are you gonna take advice?
Are you gonna take life advice from a ghost?
Are you gonna take life advice from someone who's dead?
Who died under mysterious circumstances?
Yes.
From a Vtuber?
Would you listen to any advice from a Vtuber?
Actually there are some very...
Smart Vtubers out there.
I got the most useless mob but I think it's kinda worth.
Actually it's not useless.
It's a companionship thing.
I'm lonely.
Gotta get both sides.
She wants us to be ghosts.
I just said I was lonely.
Oops.
Oopsie.
Thank you for the five gifts.
Thank you.
I believe that gum would stick all over my stomach.
But gum... gum... that actually doesn't digest for like...
There's our cat.
Our cat.
Wait, they don't love us.
Could you give a moe moe...
Hey, whoa, whoa.
Stay back from the...
Stay away from the edge of the world, cat.
Give a moe moe kyun to your multivitamin.
Oh my gosh.
You are being healthy.
Make it delicious.
Moe moe kyun.
Lins stones.
Grand Dad.
What do you have?
Amethyst shard.
We could buy this cow, I think.
Wait, do I have enough?
I think we can buy this cow!
Let's go fishing.
I need fish.
Fish.
Kyuntax.
Gone fishing.
Nice.
Oh, come on.
Fishy business.
Please bless this sleep aid supplement as I try...
and fist fight the sleep paralysis demon.
Okay, I read that correctly.
But at first I did not...
At first I did not...
At first I did not read that correctly.
Let me get my cat first.
Is that okay?
Oh, what are you doing over there?
Pss pss pss pss pss pss pss.
No no no no no.
I have more.
Come here, cat.
Cat, come here.
Cat.
Whoa whoa.
Oh, cat.
There we go.
Okay, come here, cat.
Come here, cat.
Get in my bed.
Get in my bed, cat.
Meow.
Yeah, yeah.
Go that way.
Don't push him off!
So we could buy a cat.
Wait, 22?
I don't know about you!
We might... Okay, it might be a race at this point.
Okay, look at this.
I'm gonna... Okay, watch.
I'm gonna order it.
Okay, now it's a race between the grass and the man.
That's... It's a race.
It's on.
It's on, baby.
Let's put some stuff away.
Actually, let's get some bone meal.
Grass versus ass.
Exactly.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
I just realized it's so late.
Chill Minecraft evening.
Do I have any more iron in here?
Nope.
I'm starting to feel a little sick, though.
Like a little woozy.
That's why I'm gonna wrap it up soonish.
Meow.
Go sleep ghostie.
I will.
Meow.
Once we get a cow, I'm a ghost of my word.
I am a ghost of my word.
I said I would not unstream until we get a cow.
What's the series goal?
I want to defeat the Ender dragon but, I also really want to see.
Meow.
I want... I don't know if I'll be doing this all day...
I don't know if it's like weekly or anything like that.
But I also want to see...
Whatever the hell this thing... what was it?
Where did it go?
Wait, what is this?
Oh, Wolf Farmer!
Wait, I need an armadillo!
There's so much stuff that they've added to this game.
I'm gonna get rid of him.
Why are you... what is... what is... what are you...
What are you being refreshed upon?
It's creeping me out.
Leave.
Please leave.
Okay.
They added cows.
Wait.
Weren't cows always?
He went night-night.
Yeah.
He was refreshing himself at the composter.
That's disgusting!
That's nasty!
Oh my god, it reeks!
What did he do?
He composted!
Oh my god.
Disgusting.
He added soil to the thing.
No!
That's so awful!
Right in front of me!
You sleep a block away... I don't put...
I don't put... I don't put piss and shit in there!
I put literal moss!
It's different!
That's not my toilet!
There's a whole void!
Moss has bugs in it.
So?
It still rots.
Look, if we're going to get into the very specifics of Minecraft.
I've murdered several people.
It's a doggy-dog world out there, okay?
And sometimes...
You know...
You have to live next to your toilet.
He's trying to help you with composing.
Look at all these diamonds!
We have so many.
I'm gonna start making some of this copper.
Maybe we can... What can I make with copper?
You could put the bed anywhere else.
You guys are so judgmental.
You guys are so judgmental!
What if I like it?
Oh wait, leave the bed.
Hold on, I want my cat to sleep with me.
Come here.
Come here, cat!
Oh my god, the purrs of a cat are like the best thing ever invented.
The best thing ever invented is making a cat purr.
You know?
I didn't know it would do that.
I know!
It's so cute!
It's so cute.
Oh!
Did you bring me some cocoa beans?
My cat brought me cocoa beans!
Nature's ASMR.
It's true.
How?
Don't...
Don't do that.
Ask how.
Rude!
Are you sure those are beans?
Tow...tow pounds!
Tow pounds!
Bed right next to a tree might not be the best plan.
Might wake up too right ill spider.
Hold on, let me get rid of my isn't sorry.
Tow pounds...
I love Paz's toe beans because since she's a tortie, since she's not completely black, one of her toe beans is pink, like her one paw, and then the other paw, her toe beans are black.
So it's really cute!
It's so cute!
She's so cute!
She's such a bad cat.
Torties are very cute, yeah.
We're really digging through this.
We're almost to 3500.
Is he on top of my cow?
Oh, he's in my...
Well guys...
Move.
We did it!
We got a cow!
Where are you going, cow?
Cow, cow, cow, cow, cow.
Cow, cow!
How did you get up there?
No, no, no, no.
Go back inside.
Go there.
Okay.
I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna put him...
I'm gonna lock him up in here.
We're gonna lock him up.
Perfect.
There we go.
He has enough room.
Probably.
And then also, we can drink his milk.
Oh, I lost my bucket.
I lost my buckets when I died!
Oops.
Yes?
What?
Can...
Excuse me?
You're so close.
We could order a wolf.
Huh.
Male cows don't have milk.
We can drink her milk.
How do they...
How do they mate them?
Hold on.
Let's make another bucket.
Oh.
Milky way?
Delicious.
Why is my cat on the ground?
Why is my cat...
What did you do?
Why are you on the ground?
Get on the bed.
Get on the bed right now.
Yeah.
There we go.
Freak phantom drinking his milk.
You wouldn't?
You wouldn't tell me you wouldn't...
You're telling me you would not drink the milk of this precious cow that was delivered from the heavens.
Anyways, guys.
Thank you for tonight.
I'm so sleepy.
Sleepy tired.
I'm gonna go to bed now.
And I suggest you all do the same.
Oh my gosh.
It's been four hours.
Holy cow.
Yeah.
I'm gonna head out.
I'll see you guys later.
Thank you for...
For watching, hanging out with me, welcoming me back home.
Sorry if I was a little low energy.
Just because, you know, it was...
It's me being tired.
I've been up for so long.
But...
I'm gonna get some good sleep.
Why don't you eat the pufferfish?
Oh.
Okay.
Did I lose the puffer?
No.
Whoa.
That was crazy.
Oh, I think I'm about to die though.
Let's eat some watermelon.
Oh.
Oh no.
Uh.
Guru guru.
This is how I die.
A sad Victorian child.
Getting the black plague.
Oh.
Cool.
You discovered it.
You discovered my lore.
And now...
And now, I have no other reason to be here.
You discovered how I died.
I am...
I am truly satisfied.
I'm seeing the light.
I can finally trust in peace now!
I can know I will no longer believe in myfourth day I went to hell.
A sad Victorian child... who died of syphilis?
Plague.
Everything.
Goodbye everybody.
Goodbye!
Oh, sorry.
Oh wait, hold on.
One second.
What was I doing?
Oh, okay, there we go.
Okay!
Now go!
Go into the light!
There you go.
Go on.
That's how it's done.
It burns!
Go outside!
Touch price!
Be a normie.
Don't be normal.
Oh, hold on.
I also... I hold on too.
Hold on.
Hold on too.
Oh!
Oh wait.
Yeah.
It's me.
You're probably wondering what I'm doing to get one nice look.